[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
yes sir
top of the morning afternoon wherever
you from
it is the Lord's Day mike check mike
check I am wild tired I ain't gonna hold
y'all
this is me powering through you know
it's one of them rough sleep nights and
so it happens sometime but I gotta I
gotta get the energy out for the runway
round came through support shout out to
Lydia Master set gig so let's go ILP
great topics this week let's have a fun
show Auntie wagon no doubt Gerald Mac OG
Bayside what's going on what's going on
bay area oh hell let's give it respect
yeah we got to keep it respectful a lot
of respectful discussions respectful
topics it's tebe version two what's
going on salute salute Lloyd Metroid I
see you in the building cogplay vengeful
Guardian Moon Rider okay okay heard
about that one
going on next pop that what up all right
necro man suzelle with the 10 super chat
good afternoon Lords anyone enjoying
Dead Space when we make we are trying to
get more remix in the future we need
more faithful remakes like this improves
on an already great storm thanks motive
yeah we gotta talk about software I have
a lot to say on that when he pull up you
know what I'm saying we got the atomic
says what's going on brother Buddha is
that my men's Buddha with a new name is
that brother Buddha just want to get
something off my chest go bird oh eagle
fly eagle fly you got your Eagles up no
doubt Philly what's up shout out to my
man Brock Purdy you know what I'm saying
you represent brocky calling brocky
Purley today see what he do and
brotherly love the city of brother love
we're enemy territory gonna be a hard
game no question salute to the Eagles my
nine is coming through we're gonna rap
we're gonna see what happens NFC
Championship I'm already housed I'm
playing with highest money that's how I
look at it I'm not supposed to be here
we lost both of our starting
quarterbacks and you gonna tell me we
got the last pick of the draft and we
fight for a chance to go to the Super
Bowl let's go I'm ready see what's going
on what else we got blind giant what's
up good morning going on is here Bay
Area
throw it up E40 in them
okay we follow okay low Metroid okay
yeah that's gonna be a big topic ducky
what up what's going on ducky I haven't
got a chance to play with you oh this
week no Destiny salute gotta get back to
it just was so good busy pycon Fusion
what's going on Galveston what's going
on solve them better mute King will be
here yeah no no no I'm late but I'm
gonna talk to the people trying to wake
myself up they waking me up astral
parrot King what up what's up it's time
it is time yes it is yes it is all right
nobody will sell five attic talk to the
people so I'll talk to the people this
is a late night check yeah
cause your boy [__] is tired what no
sleep yeah
very little sleep yeah are you in the
same pocket okay
Robert Kelly what up all right so this
attic is correct what's supposed to come
in any minute blow us up with his uh his
musical choices so he's gonna be oh all
right I got the second Super Chat tip
whale five dollars to the chat I've been
waiting for another episode of king and
the other guys
yo you wild disrespectful get them back
where's my wrenches at where about where
am I doing
man sees him I hope I hope that tip will
fall over
what if King no shut up what if we make
him no show then you gotta listen to the
other guys and this is ganks this is not
gangster list Sundays
well who's listening
later
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard the boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you I always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell her Uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable why can't
it be and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to an even though I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnito who cares if he flies you still
a mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke King
David still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I'm encouraged with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord radio
[Music]
yo yo bike check bike check let me just
see some levels real quick
yo yo hello
is he talking to us who is he talking to
No Doubt here you hear ye and we are
live and welcome to the iron Lords
podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 289
getting close to 290 y'all
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the round table in the realm of the
Lords or the Lord's day and today we've
got that Xbox developer direct Phil
Spencer's IGN interview follow-up
Dead Space Impressions lately
very light very lightly if you change
the plan sorry shout out to high five
Rush Hogs work Hogs work Legacy uh chat
gbt and Sony meeting with the EU maybe
to discuss
um
maybe to discuss quickly so we can get
right into it so let's introduce the
Four Horsemen of gaming these original
gaming next to the room here at the
round table Marco holds with the comos
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf Lord
Act of the attic show and rno how we
doing sir doing pretty good man had had
a pretty good uh week gaming has been
crazy here lately like you know I I did
that for you
I mean everyone kind of did to be honest
with you good and bad
you got the you got the bottom tier of
the game something like uh you know
forespoken and then you got the high
tier of the game
I mean look
I I did play it yeah he played it so he
had yes yes so I
I do think people there are things that
I feel like people is capping on and
there's things I don't feel like
people's talking about enough you know I
I feel like the movement's very clunky
like sometimes I'll be like y'all want
you to jump on top of this hill and the
game's like no but she's too fast she's
going well she's gonna jump past the
hill so I I feel like maybe they they
should have you know how like when you
played miles in Spider-Man you had that
slow motion thing where you could choose
where you wanted it to go to on the back
like they needed something like that you
know maybe because I only played like
five six hours I dropped it uh but you
know hopefully maybe you know let longer
in the game they give you more movement
options and powers and stuff I
I don't think this is a 60 game I I
think this is like you know 60 dollar
game not 77 no I I think it's like um I
would I would say from what I played of
it I would give it like a 70 something I
I don't think it's a 60 game I think the
game looks good the movement is clunky
at times I think the combat's really
good it's just that that story man that
story there's there's occasions where it
like literally makes no sense like
she'll go from being in New York to
being in this fantasy world and it's
like she she already accepts it like a
mad quick like it's like there's no
build up to it she walks out has some
conversation with that annoying cup
thing it's like oh okay Jarvis with
Jarvis yeah
wow yeah wow he do sound like him though
I I I don't I understand people's rights
but I do think there are people that's
capping too much for the game and I do
think there are people that
are being too harsh on the game okay
fair enough and you obviously playing
other things yeah Hi-Fi Roche I've been
playing that and I was gonna have the
Fire Emblem review but then Hi-Fi Rush
came out just ruined my whole week so um
bad way sir in a good way
we'll get all we'll talk about that
later oh okay okay that last minute sir
yep that's it no doubt and of course we
have children in the back but it was
same to them
of course we have of those technical
gaming Lord the solo game released for
the single player selfish experience and
also the starstradamus the Lord of
clarity and Lord patreon of the iron
bake my man Lord Sovereign how we doing
sir I'm in the bushes but I'm here I'm
good I'm doing well
generally generally yeah you know
not much gaming a lot of downloading of
games that I intend to play at some
point
on the business I got all the
achievements for downloading
get that game pass engagement exactly so
as such being under the bushes I'm very
grateful for a package I received in the
mail earlier
[Music]
oh let's go baby that it's not full with
the beverage of choice because I
honestly I need I need more during the
course of the no I would need like two
or three of these but fantastic
fantastic
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question yes sir are you hitting that
gummy life though
[Applause]
listen I was waiting for the show
okay okay
your bestgt.com
open the package right the first thing
that pops out the packets
was that Chris shot it well you
officially purchased yo bro we got that
we got that go get that iron little pack
is fresh you're gonna be part of the
gummy group
the question is we might be pushing
powder and gummies but why ain't you
guys buying it exactly we
we are concerned with everyone's
well-being You Know Carl got my my big
tall self in the gym so so let's go the
bigger question is why aren't you guys
participate exactly to get man with the
horn knowing that he heard the gummies
hit different you know I'm gonna tell
you Rick Nelson he's coming she's
banging the poles and this is all this
is all Cog over there machinate and be
like yo y'all need this I need this I
need that the other yeah and they were
like that no doubt COPD
the drink for the head and the nails and
she said oh my God they're gonna taste
delicious I said this this can't be
healthy it's Kevin
if you feel like it's candy it tastes so
good man y'all better go get that you
see the link in the description at the
top and at the bottom go get that you
was called iron Lord and check out but
continue
I mean honestly not much gaming man I
wanted to get that dead space on did not
happen high five Rush when I saw it I
was like well I'll talk about how I felt
about when I initially saw it but uh you
know just seeing this course around it
afterwards like wow number again what
downloaded but not played
we could just talk about you know
remakes being done right because I do
feel like there are people that will
complain of a remake don't sell well
yeah but then you got people actually
doing the remakes well and theirs are
actually selling so you know we can take
that angle yeah that's definitely
yeah but that's pretty much been it no
doubt and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
ooh the prophet of Xbox Swami King of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
I'm doing fantastic but I'm in the
bushes
and I need every last little bit of
focus I can get
put it
so I turned my PlayStation on yeah and I
was like yo let me get into this
PlayStation because yo not for nothing
The Last of Us
more
I was like did that happen in the game I
gotta go back
you know I got to remaster jump so let
me get in there and start playing that
so while I was downloading I said let me
play a game that I had on the back
burner that I wanted to play Forever
A's gone wow okay okay come back Deacon
frustrated yeah man I'm like I played
that damn return though okay okay
you should love today let's go all right
so I can say return on for me
looks nice in every cutscene
and then when it gets to the game
the game looks above average right okay
but it's not about probably visuals with
the game it's the replay Loop yeah uh
which is uh what's really fun I know
it's a little shocking for some people
that don't understand like those type of
games uh roguelikes and
to see the body there it is a mind trip
it's a good game right so I had a little
bit of fun with that but day's gone
let's go
it looks so dope like when I'm driving
through the hills on a bike and you know
dude's just complaining about a bike it
feels like a heavy bike that he has all
the stuff on it that's what it feels
like and then you get off the bike and
um the aiming and the tracking that
stuff feels really good I like the
density of the forest
um
the face shoes could have used a little
bit of a naughty dog love they could
have you know helped them with the you
know the motion capture of the faces but
they came pretty close
and to convey some type of emotion it
was really done well so I got up to a
little bit of probably like an hour or
so in the game and I'm I'm really liking
the game right now and then um back on
the Xbox I5 Rush yeah ridiculous yeah
absolutely I thought if if you'd asked
me and if I and I didn't have the
control in my hand
what where was that game from I would
have said uh Dreamcast or or or
something like that we got that Sega
energy yeah oh we're gonna get into it
really dope stuff yeah um
playing fortnite yes all right
I have to bend any oh
I think fortnite
is the most influential most important
Atticus most Innovative most topical
game ever made
and I say this
because remember I was clowning on this
game
I got I logged in yesterday because I
was playing some dudes early and then I
left and I came back I was like let me
get some games and right before Dennis
Cook
and immediately I was thrust into a
concert
right now it's it's a kid that I've
heard his music before
and but this is the the best thing like
to like if you have an artist and you
want to get him to millions of people
get her to millions of people
you can go this Fortnight route it was a
small board you know the board
constructs and then it's stuff that you
got to do but at the same time it's
playing this Dope music and this concert
is going on and it's an interactive
concert that you're running around and
you're seeing the stuff and the guys on
the screen and the way that it was used
it was used so topical so good
and we didn't have no downtime no
maintenance
and they put this big section in this
game and then at the end you're dancing
in this concert jamming out to music
my mind was fried completely blown away
I said this has got to be
the best implementation of uh pop music
what's current and game
and it all seems fresh new and relevant
I said this is the it's ridiculous and I
understand why everybody is chasing
games with a service because if you're
able to do it like this you will be the
top dog this this is a reason why Apex
actually ain't beating it uh uh Warzone
can't beat it it's a reason why and this
thing is it's a it's a monster within
itself there the thing about it too
is
it's just the the amount of time that
they put into these concerts because I
remember seeing the Andrea Grande one it
was like obviously that kind of music
isn't my thing but like it was it was
crazy the way they did it like she was
like some some mercy from OverWatch
armor like coming down these stairs like
it's insane the presentation they do it
like what a team over there when the
Dragon Ball Z event was happening you
could watch the TV show in in its own
event like literally the TV show is
being played at like 24 7. if you wanted
to watch it episodes oh that's crazy
it's it's born on the most topical most
current and they can switch on a fly
yeah yeah so to say like very adaptable
yeah ridiculous but that's all I've been
doing you know outside getting chicken
dinners and stuff and I I do feel like
there is an issue in the industry where
people
what's wrong I'm looking for
they people are trying this fortnite
money so much but they have they don't
have they don't have the the Mind Vision
to to make this kind of product and I I
do think it's an issue too because it's
good as good as fortnite is and as good
as epic has done with that game
that isn't an everything like people are
trying to mimic it you have people that
have had to do it their own way that has
to have some form of success but I think
that there's an issue now where too many
people are trying to do it and we have
stuff like you know potentially Suicide
Squad going down the Avengers yeah
Anthem where you have these developers
that is loved by all so like trying to
get this this um you know this money
train going on and it's I think it is
hurting the industry
you can't catch that wave because it's
like the entire company is dedicated to
that to that and and the the Unreal
Engine that's it they stop everything
yeah just for that so it's like who else
is going to do that like nobody's going
to be able to compare that's one thing
I've noticed I'm like I see all these
other like you said all these other
companies trying to hand at it but you
know again Halo infinite the perfect
example also it's just unless you're
willing to dedicate that amount of time
and resources to it it's never going to
compare to that
come on
come on no numbers
he said I didn't see that news
what happened to the Xbox
um what numbers
oh okay I see what you doing okay they
don't report numbers that's what we're
doing I want to know the numbers for
spoken
let's go
what's the numbers for spoken
since y'all so curious about uh talking
numbers
I mean since the numbers is a thing here
we go I mean you show me yours I knew
this clap back is coming all right
don't sit down man you got a 70 game
that you can't return
Microsoft double drop kid I guess it's a
PlayStation 5 topic week
well you know their numbers dropped and
so differs spoken go sit down sir
go go get some duct tape
put that game back together again
anyway has that been it so I just had to
give you I had to get a round one
because I see a couple of people you
know you know they've been out here but
they don't know man I think we shoot
right back
okay I see them I see what we doing all
right we're back on track and that's
been in circles
I was smart Okay and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the Shinobi
Lord cognitos right now running to the
run of the IOP not telling what you want
to hear what you need to hear shout out
to Mr batty play Shout out to Friday
Duke had a good one talking about that
developer direct which we will get into
and some little Oreo cookie debate was
kind of interesting people be doing
weird things Oreo cookies bro like
what's going on you dip your choice in
milk no like yeah I mean I don't even do
that but the thing is that's not even
the issue the issue is dudes like
breaking them down and I'm like at that
point you might as well just make a
shake but anyway
I I heard that discourse and no no no
Oreos cookies if it's broken up it
already comes like that from Breyers
yeah or you go to Five Guys you get the
ones with the cookies yeah anyway enough
of that go check out that for if y'all
want that debate which is kind of funny
shout out to Boston
we got almost 600 people and only 130
days saving the kids hit that like every
like y'all don't hit there's an
endangered species
see you guys this way man hit that like
button or King will talk about combat in
like 30 minutes the dodo bird is on his
last legs
and I hit that like button man but um
talking and Destiny talking ready for
life all talking about marketing debate
I have a Travis which is kind of funny
which is absolutely hilarious he's funny
and then um what else we got for me game
wise I gotta touch a little bit of that
high five rush we will get into man wow
what a what a surprise what a surprise
it is to see what it's doing we will get
into that still grinding Final Fantasy 7
Crisis Core man really enjoying it I've
been doing it on all the little missions
this great little backstory between what
happened uh for Final Fantasy VII so uh
what's up quick question now that you're
playing a lot more of that game do you
understand why that game is so relevant
to it yeah
I'm so glad I'm playing it and
especially now with remake coming out
with part two for those who ended remake
or Playstation like you know they are
doing something different and the thing
now is okay how does the past relate and
I need to know about the past so
learning about that learning is over the
top this and and what he's going through
with Shinra is really interesting and
about Genesis and Angel and early
sephiro off and yeah I'm feeling it man
I'm feeling and my the material Fusion
system at first I was like but I'm I'm
starting to get into it you're starting
to get to begin
my personal opinion is I I've said this
for over and over again you know uh the
fact that they named the game rebirth
um I I think the last boss of rebirth is
going to be Genesis
um there's a lot going on right there
and I love their flipping the Universe
on this akw you out of pocket for that
comment um so I saw what you said but
I'm gonna let you ride so so question
for people to come into the series off
the rip yes is it in terms of order of
play you should still play the original
first then Play remake it's actually
crisis cool you probably should play
first prices
literally first in the timeline so like
you know that you know that big Buster
sword that cloud has that came from that
yeah okay yeah well I mean it came from
Angie on them
you'll learn like the history of it I
will say though I know a lot of people
you could tell it's an older game by the
dialogue the dialogue give it away you
know what I'm saying because it's like
it's it's over the top a lot of anime
Japanese tropes okay guys I'm the number
one and yeah I'm gonna be a hero Zach is
very like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
ridiculous like At first I was like bro
I don't know if I could get through this
with him at first when they first
started he's ridiculous so I was like
all right I'm gonna try to stick in
there but as it's heating up but then
what it is is his Blinder not spoiled
but where he at he think is love and he
doesn't understand what's really going
on he's starting to put it together but
yeah that's pretty much raised to think
Shenron is like some Godly company yeah
and that he's reading to be his his like
his idols
and then he just finds out like real
fast which is most of the time your
Idols can turn out to be just as bad
people yeah you find out what's going on
with your peoples and his you see what's
going on but I love the material system
I love the DMZ I'm getting more Summons
of grinding out missions because they
let you grind missions before you go
into the main at any point of the game
so every save point you can grind
missions and I'm doing that because I'm
getting more stuff more equipment more
different material more stuff so salute
to that and then on midnight science man
DLC shout out to that day cool oh that's
why people were saying that on Twitter
yeah
people are people are saying I gotta
have Hi-Fi Rush your car's still going
to be playing Midnight yeah bro this is
what happens because everybody comes in
when are you gonna play Death Loop you
said just gonna play Death loop I get it
like Crisis call was on on the docket
first of all midnight Stars took up all
the time right it's not a short game
that's not a short game it's 100 plus
hours and I still got more stuff and I
still have it 100 completed it and I
want to get 100 uh my full game score in
that game so you got that so I was going
to do that whatever whatever that that
shut down I still didn't play higher
life that's how bad midnight sons took
my life away so you got that damn I've
been said I was going to play crisis
because I'm a final fantasy I know how I
give it up for something yeah I know so
I was like that I never played that
addict but telling me about that that's
the prequel is going great game so I'm
loving that and then
there's an Xbox gonna drop high on Rush
high five Russian I'm like oh man like
you were not supposed to be here like
what are you doing what are you doing
being great here right now so it's just
saying about the plan now is after
Crisis Core death Loop is next that is
literally the plan so I know y'all gonna
come for me I know this land is coming I
get I welcome this Lander for Deaf love
I deserve it but it will get down
believe that slander at home I will take
it shout out to everybody YouTube must
be making some updates someone super
chatted for the first time and have told
us they said yeah there were some
changes yeah yeah it's to celebrate that
celebrate that first Super Chat oh
that's dope I never see that all right
that's what's up I really like that yeah
no doubt no doubt in this shout out to
Sinister yeah they got me they they
bullied me in the Call of Duty that one
now yeah I know I know yeah so we got
that but um yeah it's been uh pretty
much it for me as far as the games we
talked oh King oh I supposed to talk to
you please can we talk about that packs
uh merchandise oh it's ready to go well
it's in the story and right now oh okay
ready to go okay cool cool cool cool
yeah
um I talked to uh the merchand guys and
um talk to a certain God and uh we got
together and talked to God
got Suave yeah I can't I can't tell you
you know anything about what Todd Howard
said
I'm under ndas
dude the videos true is the sourcing
true you need to check the check clip
anyway so
we have packs East
shirts that's in the store right now
right now
and
I would say hurry up and get them right
because they're limited edition that's
one
two if you happen to be in the Pax area
we're working on things for people that
do happen to have that particular pack
shirt
and when we're at Pax so
my suggestion to you
let's run to the store yeah copper packs
East 2023 shirt yeah links in the
description iron Lords podcast
and there's good things to follow but
also everything that y'all do everything
that you purchase every time you're
super chat helps us on our road to E3 if
you can look at the tally at the bottom
that's the tally that's going to get us
to uh I said E3 packs uh 2023
um so that's going to help us get there
so please again
go check out the merch no doubt and have
a variety of colors I like that white
and gold to be honest with you that's
that's my flavor
you know what I would like to do
eventually you know after E3 impacts
Easter then
I'd like to do a good giveaway for
people that own all the pack shirts
um
you still have a pending console
giveaway for when we hit 15K yeah you
you show us that you you have all those
packed shirts you might do a giveaway
with just those individuals
from every year we've done it day ones
no doubt salute salute so yeah we got
that arm and then obviously yo shout out
to valari shout out to go check that out
we got that get the IOP exclusive I'm
seeing my UK veteran I'm seeing my EU
Bridges they putting them orders in they
got that trusty valari at their side
valarian steel around gaming hello
[Applause]
and I want to say again like you guys
have no idea how much you guys turned up
for those pillows
like when we get good results when we do
these little because we're new to this
we're new to this but when we could show
these companies yo we can move products
like our Our Community Trust our our
opinion they know that you know we you
know I might joke about being bought but
you know you pay part of me you know
adding but you know we we we are people
that we we wouldn't push something on
you that we wouldn't use ourselves
exactly and factual factual and and
because you know we've established that
that trust with you guys and you guys
really go out there and you show good
like we can use those metrics to be like
yo you know we we can do this for you uh
we we can we we have this to offer
I'm just trying to sneak my pillow in
and relax
when he said it I was like I mean oh
it's right here man
I'm saying No Doubt yes
with my chair with my chair if I try to
put it on it'll be like in my chest like
it's gonna be like a like a floatation
dusting my hands on the hand rest and I
was like it's so uncomfortable got it
yeah and then I looked over in my pillow
I was like yeah I was just getting hold
on man
yeah
trolling your hair you good you can
relax a little bit right now I think I
think I got three hours
yo y'all what do it again us UK EU link
is in the description at the top in the
chat use code Lord 15. I always mess
this up I always say Cold Island no Lord
15 for 15 of our exclusive pillow go
check that out it's in there you already
know and um of course obviously I don't
Advanced GG and all that but um we got
to do some uh real quick but actually
before let me get the switches I gotta
do describe it all out yeah yeah that's
fine but uh
we had no mention of R and R this week
hey man
addict so that that show the anime
with the gods versus the humans or not
the naked people do you mean do you mean
that the ones where the fake Lord solves
and Laura Cognito shut up and super
chatted this here you mean that one yeah
oh no no you mean the imposter's coming
in there
I mean as I as the iron back I'll gladly
go in and renege those uh
you don't feel it's real
[Laughter]
the question uh for the children you
know me me and King we made another
channel for uh for that the r r with the
Lords you know for those people that
want a little bit more info on stuff
like that I'm putting it the uh the link
in the chat so definitely go in there uh
sub to that you know let's let's get
that uh let's get some people over there
only if you like TV and stuff like if
you don't really interested in that
content don't go over there just because
you're trying to support uh I do I'll go
over there yes
they don't want that type of content I
don't want I I would prefer justice
so marketing 101. ain't trying to have
people that's not gonna watch the videos
he said we don't want you over here if
you like that type of content that's for
you if you don't um it's okay he's
excluding everyone else
if you like me and you support me go
over there right now click that button
super chats uh we got two that you read
earlier but I'll read them again
necromances they'll remember for one
year ten dollars good afternoon Lords
anyone else enjoying Dead Space remake
if we are to get more remakes in the
future we need more faithful remix like
this improves on an already great story
I'm assuming thanks motive no doubt
motive finally gets to make a game
that's crazy
I haven't played it but they to what I'm
seeing the people I trust like BG yeah
they did a really good job
people who love playing the same stuff
over and over again oh here we go
is that coming from the person that
plays fortnite over and over again for
months at a time
it's just it's just gold playing tilted
Towers now I can land until the towers
two times in a row the kid is not in the
game you know you know
can't be pushing us because he can play
any Marvel version
just when it's something that he like
you know the remix
everything it's something I like I care
look Apollo Cooper I'm not the greatest
of fortnite but can you can tell you I
can hold my own all right oh yeah
but he's sitting there sending Slanders
things this way but this like every day
hey hey man what's up we in here
I was playing I was playing a Hi-Fi Rush
last night and I and I got an invite
from King on fortnite and I thought to
myself King you know damn well I ain't
coming off of this well no listen I had
to shoot my shot
see you over there having fun but you
know you see your peoples out there I
gotta shoot my shots
I'm a break protocol and jump a little
bit real quick
five dollar Super Chat I'll go support
the other channel of attic shows a
little bit of pasty legs
we can throw it up for the set it's
going to be like one of the uh one of
those calf commercials like oh no
no no
no it'll be like one of this is this the
calf that you're looking for
we can't that's not the only Fair's
attic world that we looking for we're
not looking for any of us
no no no no that's not to go don't put
no goals on the bottom for that
hashtag naked ankles keep those bees
alone
then we have X God five dollar Super
Chat I've been watching you Xbox dudes
y'all was crying about every little
thing Game Awards this Halo and 343 this
I could smell the Kool-Aid from here
[Music]
now they feeling like kings you're a
false King oh oh
you wasn't down with the set when they
was down now you're here when they up
despicable oh so oh
okay I don't know
you know what the trenches
I get it their King is forespoken
continuing wow okay they just found out
that they they King don't wear any
underwear that's was it ever no clothes
no clothes the outside snitching yo how
do you rep a snitch I I just don't get
it y'all all out here with Gunner face
hey yo
y'all not ponies no more you're gonna
gutters
what's your big what's the team name
gonna why your cell is a game you try to
attribute these attributes to a whole
gaming family
why is selling the game
I see Jefferson
do you understand Teletubbies I've seen
them wow
not the RICO kick when we moving on
continue inside jokes
we got hard to find remember for 21
months Lord bronze assalamu alaikum my
brothers
yes sir
how long have you had how long have I
been saying that we're going to the
Super Bowl all season I had your ticket
but you didn't accept
49.
this is hard to find hard to find he got
your ticket no listening
I'm just not popping off like I listen
49ers I love y'all but like we gotta
understand this was not in the script
right we lost two quarterbacks and star
quarterbacks then Mr Irrelevant come and
Lead like just enjoy the ball but the
dudes is like yo what's going down like
I'm enjoying it babe
just just I don't know I I don't I don't
do the football thing but one thing I
will say is I'm happy for you I
appreciate it I appreciate it he's
watching Friday night football with me I
wasn't watching nothing
I lost it now you're going too far too
far
that we have let me see David hot right
remember for one year ten dollars per
Tap Happy Lord's Day from Philadelphia
Phillies
I'll be watching the game later today
yeah cool if the Eagles pull it off but
if the Niners win it it's all good
because I can be I can be happy for cops
it's the Super Bowl today there's the
level wins in these games
whoever wins both games both teams go to
the Super Bowl two ball yeah yeah it's
four teams playing right now is the
elimination yes sir but we got solved
then we got tipped whale
got a pole just for [__] pause okay
all I can do is shake my hair bro keep
going would Cog rather a eat an onion
sandwich B finish Elden ring or C I
don't care vampire survivors is STS
that was good that was good
dude I'm bad surprise
on your sandwich and y'all know I don't
like Elder Rick so that is what it is I
mean you know I respect of the ring but
it ain't my thing like that you know
like the game would be here
I'll take that stand out I like that I
like your S10 games
[Laughter]
you may call wear anything or eat
anything he like you guys win yeah
who the hell had Booker T was doing the
spinning Rooney it was pissing us off
who had Booker T I think oh I think it
was Kai Kai Kai yeah yeah
but the crest in the chat for the first
Super Chat from vinster X11 two dollar
Super Chat baby I really appreciate that
I like this little shout out I like that
that's what's up oh shout out to my man
Wilhelm scream up in the chat after
doing this sir that's my man New York
gonna build it salute good to see you up
smash the like button say so we're
endangered animals every time you do it
continue
we have Hollywood rules remember for one
year five dollars for chat Cog done
chains IOP to Box Dale and crew from The
Wire yeah
we got that pandemic that get that wmd
that wfd
actually I actually watched like the
first season of The Wire I didn't go
past that no bro you got to watch that
watch that
oh I shouldn't have said that King's
gonna make me watch this no I'm not
saying anything no I'm not gonna do that
to you continue but it's great it's
great it's great have a great show
Brothers I'm loving Hi-Fi rush so far
hashtag Game Pass
love serious Metacritic killer yes sir
and we have detective seats twenty
dollars for the chat thank you there's
somebody's named I'm like okay where'd
you get that for real quick okay some
funds for PAX East thank you brother
appreciate that thank you you're the
detective seeds so so who he working
with Gunner
I will be there as well and we'll and
we'll have to meet up no doubt yeah
definitely pull up pull up make sure you
have on that shirt have a great show and
a week my guys you as well brother
appreciate blessings make sure you have
on the shirt
[Laughter]
played Hi-Fi rush and it's freaking
awesome the only issue I had with the
game is playing through the cloud doing
a beat and it's froze up oh hey Cloud so
yeah I mean a rhythm-based game maybe
you want to play it as locally as
possible yeah no doubt we have Lucius
Augustus member for 17 months Lord
bronze Hi-Fi Rush standing at a 91 an
open critic with 14 reviews that's a
great start of the year for Xbox let's
hope they can keep this quality this
year that is beautiful out of the blue
that's crazy again yeah we're gonna talk
about Tango man we'll talk we got stuff
to talk about yeah for sure we have THX
1138 two dollar Super Chat fortnite VR
on psvr too now that's the metal version
oh that would be sick crazy they get
that they'll be saying oh oh hold on
somebody that chop that packs eats
Butters okay we get it let's get it
beautiful oh no they got that they got
the Lord Cog Joy oh they got the Lord oh
no that's not the shirts
somebody copped it white oh somebody
just copied to the white guy there we go
that's the first move out here but I'm
saying though don't think you're gonna
come up below your [__] I need to talk
to you
he's like yeah what's up where's Kyle
let me do my numbers B excuse me king I
need to talk to Kyle you got that powder
absolutely I see y'all we got the homie
hard get your name remember for one year
five dollar Super Chat salute to the
Lord's Xbox subpoena Sony for their
numbers and lions and Ryan runs to the
EU telling lies about what Xbox is
offering on parody
shout out to the legendary miles don't
PA in the chat I see you I see you then
we have Chris McComb with the five pound
Super Chat I've started playing the
Persona games do you recommend using a
walk through or playing it without Mike
uh Mike's sons was amazing but midnight
sounds amazing nine games of the year
last year yeah nice I would defer the
attic for the Persona invited I couldn't
I couldn't give that game of the year
because of the clothes man it's just
everybody's not supposed to be wearing
skin tight shirts and skinny jeans bro I
mean other than that a lot of heart
beats everybody wearing a heartbeat I
don't know if he's talking about like
Persona 5 or you know if it's the one I
played Persona 5 yeah the only time I
generally go towards like a guide or
anything like that online is once I've
pretty much wanting to face like in-game
stuff stuff that's stronger than the
last boss and I want like the best stuff
you can go in there with I want the uh I
want the okie dokie sword like I feel it
I feel that salute salute to him playing
in games yes
and we have skate lights five dollar
Super Chat how many Xbox Studios we
don't know what they're working on and
have had lots of Dev time how many of
those will be Shadow dropped I like to I
like the shadow drops I like it and you
could look at this and you know if I
Hi-Fi Hi-Fi rush and it's just like
you're looking at this game and now
you're like the cops I see y'all y'all
rev it I see y'all that's love salute
and just so you guys know if you don't
see the number going up that the pack
stuff the Teespring stuff doesn't
immediately impact the number on screen
so it's really just super test that
we're able to see but everything else is
being calculated too so absolutely any
which way you support us it's going
towards that absolutely yeah we don't
have a way of uh incorporating the merch
into the goal but we least wanted to
give y'all the love so that when y'all
see it pop up that we know everybody
copped it the support is there so much
love on that then we have Hollywood
whatever detective sees that bought that
he said
[Laughter]
we have Hollywood rolls member for one
year two dollar super chat now addict is
talking about moving product IOP equals
the wire on the outside I mean if
there's anybody understood we should
talk about moving product it would be
the person named
addicted
the name oh somebody copped a little bit
oh the little big hoodie moving out here
yeah
what it is
then we have we got jumped a little bit
Italian brown two dollars in the chat do
the leg slap addict yeah so they want to
see the leg with like barbasol on it and
then you slap itself shout out to that
guy Scream he cop that little man all
right I see you salute salute that was
you this is not on those attic we will
be not showing no questions
wait till the camera comes on take those
dreams someplace don't you do that don't
you is it is it still overheating addict
yes
I'm about to turn it back off
[Laughter]
yeah two dollar Super Chat lying dance
moves been busy this week yes we're back
back at work okay
he was like oh I got to get over to the
EU
he was trying to get to the ER he wind
up in the EU yeah
you stupid he's stupid he's retired
shout out to Chris Jones he said oh he
got that he put out these codes y'all
for Quest exactly um the arrival rides
okay okay beautiful thank you appreciate
that log net in the building salute you
get those codes uh give a shot on the
chat yeah
speaking of codes I think I'll give a
couple out today yes yes because we have
a ton of cold weeks and a whole ton of
um
that's for the chat so he's calling
front of the chat
yeah he's the way he was very aggressive
brother
I guess he didn't like them dudes
hungry Jimbo better eat those brussels
sprouts
wow
[Laughter]
baby cabbages
who the hell put baby cabbages
I got a question for the chat for a code
for a game okay what what is the first
what is the emote that was created from
me and King bickering about sea of
Thieves
um
that's a good one wow I don't remember
that I remember that I do remember it I
think this king was always right
y'all remember
do you remember
first you want to put it in the chat uh
where the OG's at where the oh geez that
y'all know that about you support your
support
second hint second hit
the reason it was used is because King
was saying a certain amount of people
was on sea of Thieves and I was joking
about it yeah
[Music]
in the bushes nope show me a bill nope
we had a fight damn y'all out of it
oh there it is Stitch
like crazy but I'll give it to you it
was Millions because the the argument
was okay
that was a good question that was a
great question dudes could not get that
yeah you had to be there you had to be
there for that one so that was the one
the kid was like yo Millions teams are
like the millions of people
and then it came out Millions he's like
oh Millions this is what it was so
that's how that's how I got this means
the first time oh that's a throwback for
the for the OG shout out to the old knee
no doubt stitch in the building make
sure he get that what else you guys know
for the next one right called make sure
they can't see the uh chat on Zoom
yeah I'm sending you a message on Zoom
oh I see it should be okay okay I'm
sending you a message not the other two
dudes
I prefer you probably it's probably
gonna come through
his father said it to be on like
Facebook or something okay that's fine
I'll put it in the chat yeah all right
cool
see that stuff now they see some
squirrel and stuff Stitch tell me if you
want that code or not so I know what to
do with it because some of you be
winning stuff and you say just give it
away like
Give It Away Give It Away give it away
now all right moving forward but before
I move forward
classic IOP jump off oh there we go oh
there we go the classic Crest in the
building salute guys huh we got phase
23b can why twenty dollars
Microsoft's main argument against Sony's
Call of Duty protest doesn't work it
defied business logic to take Bethesda
games away from PlayStation but look
where we are now oh Define logic to have
games I don't know the five business
logic necessarily that think about it
that was at a time when we were still
looking at a little bit of the wall
Garden even with game pass around so it
makes sense many sense
appreciate you brother
then we have Apollo Cooper five dollar
Super Chat we were wondering why Phil
had that look at the vgas then boom
Hi-Fi Rush Jeff he don't need your game
award he's grilling chicken and ribs
that Reed pop wow yeah they were sitting
on that one I don't know if they still
should have been at the awards but they
they said on that yeah definitely said
oh addict Stitch said he won the games
please
send me a message on Twitter uh so I
will go [__] he gonna act like he don't
got you as a friend he makes he's he
attic is social strategic he's making
sure that you follow him
countering the failed logic of face 23
became
industry in the chat streets uh Cod does
not define gaming if Cod fails Paul Tony
will just will be just fine solo gaming
and Xbox hasn't removed any games from
PlayStation and uh and MP games continue
to get up multiplayer games continue to
get updates stop capping oh oh
Facebook are you trying to get Facebook
out of there
waiting for the Gunners yeah yeah we got
Robert Kelly Two Dollars of a chat can't
believe Sony spent money on foreclosure
wow
[Music]
that's crazy continue right that was
wild yeah yeah that was that was crazy
somebody in the chat named himself for
smoking yeah yeah I really uh
excited about this game right now
about a second I'm rolling back a little
bit we have Lord Metro two dollars Super
Chat Jim at the ER hook me up with
morphine add-on with a morphine add-on
that's right you know with all uh with
the shade that Square Enix be given Xbox
here lately you know I forespoken you
know are you good with it
you guys all all of it in the chat man
if you want a clown clown you know
because they got no problem clowning on
us and not getting the city of that game
revenge tour continue then we have
drunken ninja remember for 29 months
Lord bronze thank you brother shout out
Phil Ace Boogie Spencer everybody gonna
eat on his
bloggy
yes that's what's up
to everybody who recognizes that
reference classic
then we have free R Kelly five dollars
Super Chat Dead Space remake is good
King you gonna have to sell your Xbox
Microsoft dropping the ball Sony
leveling up again he's back in pockets
okay okay did you get the duct tape
it came with your broken game
they don't get refunds they mean a lot
of duct tape
we got we got zero back five dollar
Super Chat packs Pax no is it packs do
or packs
though he's like what up though
you know
what's crazy we're already close to
hitting our first like uh Milestone
[Music]
that is it we are caught up sir good we
can finally start the show no we can't I
mean oh no here we go
free R Kelly two dollar Super Chat Sony
don't claim for spoken
that was crazy
seven dudes yeah
I did that giveaway and I just had like
15 people falling
salute salute that's right wait a second
wait a second wait a second I had to
give it a week so you got your caught up
cause I got to do scrub I gotta we're
good we're caught up right look y'all
it's long date time you know we do
launchgamer.net in the building the best
Young Riders in the game up and coming
tremendous Talent man love everybody on
the team yo I want to salute a team for
real for real like we had a tremendous
month like we destroyed it as a complete
team I think biggest site traffic ever
in its existence Lord you gave me that
in the month of January put your hands
together for the team everybody out
there killing it editorial writers
describes everybody doing their thing
this is for my man dizzy division is
still continuing we try to keep his name
alive because I love what we stand for
what we represent and uh yeah man it's
that time we got to celebrate the Scribe
man the one who went above and beyond in
the month of January he killed it with
the strategy games killed it with the
top five games top five strategy game
article Danny also had uh I believe a
demio
um what you call the guide as well as
the interview with rival rides you know
what I'm saying in VR so we proudly
present the latest winner of the Dizzy
long net scribe of the month for January
my man Lord sisters to see you Nick
Chris Jones back at it repeat winners we
don't say he did that look he could not
be here to accept it in person but he
left us some bars right quick so we
gotta let him get his balls off right
quick
what's going on everybody it's your boy
Chris Jones AKA scene at one two three
one two three aka the Michael Jordan log
net soaking an expert unit Chronicles
expert we're back again I know you see
me last month we're back to back and
Scribe of the month two months in a row
just want to say shout out to all the
editors and other writers for lognet we
do amazing work over there we out here
breaking the internet
so make sure you get all your gaming and
media news over at lordsgaming.net and
make sure you check out ILP every Sunday
iron Lord's doing the Lord's work on the
Lord's Day shout out to Cog SOB addict
and King make sure you go check out all
the extra streams attic does playing
games like Fire Emblem and even playing
Mike Tyson punch you I happen to learn
on the Fly attic is killing it over
there so make sure you show us all love
and support we appreciate you and don't
forget the Lords will be at PAX East and
officially
Chris Jones will also be joining the
Lords of PAX East that's right
I'll be there
so make sure you show us some love and
support I'll catch you next time
slew
see you net in the building subscribing
them all back to back in that joint
salute man absolutely killing it brother
absolutely putting us in the poor house
that he calls his number he's like
Beirut yeah and he goes for it he's
taking that 23 very seriously right now
yeah for real 23 seriously I salute that
he gonna be with us at Pax you know what
I'm saying PAX East pull up you know
what I mean it's gonna be a good time
salute to him and then a secondary war
that we just started not that long ago
we wanted to salute the editorial team
the heroes the unsung heroes behind the
scene through all the Dirty Work get us
looking good got the articles on time
everything right but um this one
particular you know he's one of the
rocks Vlog that you know I don't feel
honestly I don't think I thank him
enough he's always killing it consistent
professionalism always helping out the
team properly sourcing articles it's a
big day before he runs with something he
gets to saw us he's killed it with his
uh Horizon forbidden West multiplayer
leak that came out I don't know if y'all
saw that he was one of the first with
Dad he's one of the first with the high
on life Departures what was going on in
the studio and he's killing it with the
Modern Warfare guys proudly present the
Lord dizzy editor of the month in the
month of January to my man Lord Undead
AKA Nicholas Dowdy slow candidates in
the building much love brother again he
couldn't make it but he had some bars
for us we gotta let the man talk speak
to me speech good morning good afternoon
I guess by the time this goes live I'm
uh the assistant editor-in-chief of
lordsofgaming.net and apparently at a uh
editor of the month for the month of
January and I just want to take a a
quick minute to thank everyone
um not necessarily for the award but
just for everything
um that's been going on Lords of
gaming.net uh this month January has
been is tracking to be our best month
ever for the website in the uh three or
four years that uh we've had the website
and it's just been phenomenal to watch
everyone grow and all the writers and
the editors come together on a daily
basis and focus on bringing great gaming
related content and ideas forward and
we're always pushing our medium forward
and I'm really proud of how hard this
team works and I could I couldn't win
this award without the amazing team that
we have at Lords of gaming and I just
wanted to give them a some quick love if
nothing else for everything that we've
done everything that we're going to do
and with the trials and tribulations
that's facing games media in 2023 it
feels great to be part of a independent
uh solution so please keep supporting
Independent Media please keep supporting
us as always we appreciate everyone that
tunes into iron Lords podcast watches
watches any of the Lord's minute content
and of course clicks and reads on our
Lords of gaming.net content coverage we
appreciate everyone and I just wanted to
take my last uh 15 seconds here to say
Cog it's time you right the wrongs and
you play and finish death Loop everyone
have a blessed Sunday and enjoy your
time in the realm
and on that note we are officially
rescinding Lords
we are rescinding his award for the
death Loop slander now that's my man
that's salute to Undead man what are the
legends of the game he's been doing it a
long time respect so much respect for
what you do brother don't thank you
enough one of our top guys top editors
always a good person to get advice from
and he kills him man absolutely kill the
salute enjoy make sure both of y'all
Chris and Nick head up solve y'all know
what it is the bank will take care of
Chris did not waste any time he put it
in yeah okay okay so what you're gonna
say you said we missed something we see
you see something did y'all see I don't
know if we had any bet on this did y'all
see that they officially confirmed that
that Forza Motorsport has no Xbox One
version I don't remember if that was
confirmed mean King was betting on PS5
for copies he has five copies of Forza
Motorsports no of Spiderman and
Wolverine which I pretty much already
won that but no I'm just saying like uh
for a guy that loves anime and all anime
is is about the little guy uh beating
the odds
at the last second
like I don't watch this anime right now
we knew this guy didn't have a shot but
he knocked Hercules out and I'm saying
attic shut up before you end up like
Hercules bro
let it happen because can you please not
stand up
if they keep dropping games like for
spoken
before Spiderman Wolverine before the
end of the year how much money you think
Jim need to recoup before he sends
Spider-Man that way think about it
because for smoking just got smoke right
now from hi-fi
I can't be going out there Jim don't
want that baby your game gonna be
cross-platform whether you like it or
not I mean it's cool like yeah I'll get
you these now or then well actually I'll
get you you're reincarnated these
because I already own your knees they
said they said they said five years on
your joint five times
so but it seems to have been confirmed
no no no last gen yeah only only Cloud
only Cloud okay we force you to upgrade
on this side
I mean that that's been kind of the
consistent thing with uh Xbox so they've
done that with the majority their uh
star Fields only next [__] I'm pretty
sure redfall is too isn't it yeah I
believe so yeah
see Xbox actually believes the
generations
so and we have a couple more Super chats
we got Matt without fear five pound
Super Chat nothing to say just happy
Lord's day and looking forward to the
Pax coverage yes so you know we're gonna
kill that you know we can do that we got
hargit to need five dollar Super Chat
wanting that smoke today pretty sure EA
plays in Game Pass not PS plus Dead
Space will come to Game Pass who's
winning free R Kelly
accidents over there
man why you why are you coming against
the dude that using his his his lunch
money to to come down there in that
Super Chat you know realistically he
can't fight you no slam today continue
There we have Matt without fear two
pound Super Chat actually I do have a
question r r podcast when yes
Tuesdays at 5 p.m on this channel okay
we got you we got you don't worry and
I'll tell you to come watch us and go
over there and subscribe
have you seen him I mean have you seen
him
then we have buck
buckets
Lawrence could Indiana Jones be a
surprise holiday 23 release movie hits
this June machine games did Wolfenstein
way back in 2017. that was The New
Colossus of 2017. damn yeah that would
be crazy
that would be crazy yeah that'd be crazy
all right last week's poll is in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the latest layoffs at 343 and the
Studio's most recent statement on their
commitment to Halo single player and
multiplayer what do you think is the
best course of action for 343 moving
forward yo this is the wildest support
we've ever did three-way tie
literally by percentage Point wins so
this was really a three-way tie at 30
but the winner of obvious excuse me
four-way poll excuse me winner of our
four-way poll with almost a three-way
tie
32.3 percent of the vote
was did could continue to deliver on the
promise of Halo infinite with a
continued single player and multiplayer
content drop group so by the edge people
want Halo to continue but this was razor
close coming at second razor close again
30.4 percent of the vote was clean slate
slowly phase out Halo infinite support
start development of the next Halo game
with the Lessons Learned in third place
with 30 flat think about this what was
the winner was 32.3 the second place was
30.4 and the third was 30 flat was
slowly pulled 343 responsibilities away
from Halo to other Xbox games deals the
realm is split and in last place selling
the messy lunch and all he said to say
was I don't care I still want my Spartan
lock spin-off game so the brown has
spoken this is the most divisive poll
we've ever done solve your thoughts on
this and somebody just bought don't [__]
up on me right now
yeah it's probably buckable
I mean I kind of felt this is going to
be this divisive right man to me look
hello infinite's still a fairly new
product do what you can with it continue
to support it as best you can and think
about the future I think when we talked
about some of the things that could
happen I'm not precious about
about doing like Side Stories and diff
different takes on Halo with other
Studios I think that'd be cool
um and you give core Halo a little bit
of a chance to rest keep supporting what
you have in infinite already think about
what the core Halo games master cheat
games whatever you want to be are moving
forward and let other teams mess around
with the world there's so much in the
world that can be done we talked about
potential third person action games we
talked about more and RPG you know you
can do so much with this world
and it doesn't have to be the core Halo
game so I'm not precious about it
do everything do everything with Halo
yeah we got some comments from Phil
after that but yeah salute to the real
man very divisive we're gonna get into
these topics finally it's been a minute
addict this is your topic however you
want to approach it we got to develop a
direct your impressions you know what
I'm saying we got high five rush we got
the Phil Spencer interview post
developer direct so whoever you want to
go with it man
um I actually you know we all watched it
you know uh shout out to us you know we
did a live reactions yeah I did it but
yeah I was literally yeah but you know
we don't care about songs
wow you guys didn't let me finish first
probably yeah I don't think he was
getting the ball going to do I don't
know you guys
sound like he was through what you would
do
so you know uh what up this is how I
wanna how I wanna do this okay I want to
ask the realm first off I want to talk
about the formation the format they're
doing how they're doing this and I want
to rate just the format no content just
how they're doing the format because we
came from stuff like inside Xbox stay to
play or Nintendo Direct I want to talk
about the way they're doing this format
and then we'll talk about this
particular show with this format and
then we'll go into uh Hi-Fi rush but
then we'll start we'll solve I I would
like to go for I would like for the
first time I like to go first for this
yeah
I see this narrative one on social media
about me and you know it's fun it's a
narrative it was brought about it
because usually I don't be in the
streets like that you know what I'm
saying so I'm not you know I'm not but
you know a couple of my dudes hit me
backflate your car that Street's got
this for you she's got it because you
know these dudes be gang gang they be
bang banging
you know I just want to explain you know
because this question actually came up
on Duke also right and you said I have
no idea what you're talking about yeah
but you know how you know how like attic
just eloquently said yo what do you
think of the format of the show and what
I realized on social media there's a
difference between when people ask you
what the format versus what they think
you think the overall rating is there's
a difference between them it's only on
Xbox right so so what would I say I
think the format is a 10 out of 10. oh
stop the captain
how dare you these fools be too excited
are you saying people don't read this
this thing called comprehension and
people don't have it and this is how you
know for the people who are confused and
you don't understand that these dudes
don't have competition look at the last
10 tweets
they last 10 tweets it's all gang gang
beef or whatever being this is back for
throwing it up for the set riding hard
for their platform but understand the
question so that's what I want to get
off and second the last I gotta get this
one there's a little bit of man talk in
King's vein dudes we gotta stop
hating on people who are enjoying
something like if something if you don't
like it you don't have to stop someone
else from liking something you don't
have to kill them like I don't like
Elder reality you know it if people on
my time like like yo Elder Rick let's
get it I don't feel the need to jump up
with a Tyler no man why you having fun
with that yo y'all doing too much y'all
doing too much Dark Souls dudes y'all
doing too much
weird energy is that like I've never
seen dudes be mad at other people
happiness this is the goofiest thing
I've ever seen bro like let people had a
moment it's okay you gonna be all right
you gonna get through this tough time
so you know what it is when they in a
tough time they don't know how long it's
gonna last
right they don't know if Microsoft uh
turned the fire up and broke the knob
off yeah and walked out the room or if
Phil is going to come back and just turn
the dial back down
you mad that's somewhere having fun
like how you mad at that I don't get
that as the weirdest I had to get my
boss you can have you definitely you can
have your opinion be like that's not for
me yeah but yeah you're like yo what do
you think about it right someone no
one's asking for your opinion fam like
no one said your fan what do you think I
need your expert opinions or how it is
you feel the need to interject when you
see everybody over here
you're saying like that that's what it
is but I just had to get it all sorry
attic for breaking protocol your
question but I just wanted to talk about
this continue yourself let me just read
this yes quick Matt without fear of five
pounds Super Chat my fault for being
cheap I don't know what you're talking
about bro
you always do your thing my question was
actually will RNR come to podcast feeds
I don't always get to catch live and
podcast is easier for ketchup oh yeah um
it's in the chat
okay so it's it has its own stuff oh we
haven't put it to um
oh yeah that's coming oh yeah yeah I
want it in Italian Spanish and French we
should have Salvage emergency
a Sony is back to Ghana
and then real quick we got Tyson Lewis
twenty dollars to protect thank you
brother appreciate you no doubt absolute
so to the question of format let's go
format
that's all clapping his hands okay
let's go
um this is what it needs to be no
questions asked don't I understand we're
going to get uh on stage energy right
come E3 come all the shows or whatever
and you know I know that like Riot has
been doing this for the longest time
obviously Nintendo Direct sort of
pioneered it in the console space uh
emulate that and that's what you did and
and I think it is the best way to a get
the developers into a light where where
gamers are happy to see them right
you're seeing them talk about the games
that you see in the studios right I love
the fact they went into the studios and
showed the studios and the devs are
talking and then it cuts off the
gameplay
um and I love that so this is this is To
Me the Way Forward especially when
you're close to release that you want to
see more about the games I I love the
format of this any games that are you
know within six months whatever even a
year coming out I think this is an
amazing format that gets the gamers
invested in the game because you're
going to see more of the game gameplay
stuff like that but then you also
invested in in the devs as opposed to
having them sit down uh in a sort of a
round table being interviewed by a host
and you have those Dynamics and
sometimes people just don't want to see
that when it's a pre-recorded thing and
you know that it's going to be them talk
about briefly about the game describing
what's happening on screen but you're
actually seeing it I think it's it's so
much better and I I think this is the
format to me moving forward that they
should utilize 100 I thought it was
great the only weirdness very very minor
things uh they had like camera angles of
camera angles of certain things like
sometimes they showed the dev talking
and the the K and but instead of the
camera being on him it was like a side
angle so it's like showing all the
angles they're recording from and it
just felt a little bit weird
um but and then in addition to that
there were some there were some games
that showed it cut too much from
gameplay and then back to the dev
talking and pack t-shirt sorry oh shout
out shout out it just it cut a little
bit too much where I wanted you know
have the dev show his face introduce
himself what they do introduce what's
happening in the clip and then stay more
on the clip of the gameplay right I want
to stay on the camera because sometimes
it feels a little disjointed when it's
jumping back and forth jumping back and
forth apart from that it amazing amazing
format loved it
they didn't have any goofy people uh
coming out talking about hi guys
controller that we got back from a buck
down Boogie
um I don't care I don't care I don't
care about a guy like hey Jim
I don't care about none of that stuff or
how dope she is as a female gamer with a
hip shirt on I don't care about none of
that show me the game show me the guys
that made the games because those are
the only people I care about I think you
don't care about anything else so I
think the problem was I don't even think
they I think they could have done the
influencer thing it's just I don't feel
like they got the people that would
resonate with us
I don't care who they get
I don't I don't care because I don't I
don't care if they have Mr Beast up
there I don't care if you didn't make a
game I don't care if you're not up there
pedaling your wares I don't care all
right so show me show me what you've
made talk about it and be proud about
your game yeah that's that's what I like
so I don't care about I swear to God I
don't I don't want to see uh controllers
and dishes I don't want to see none of
that stuff save that back to Bucktown
Boogie they've got four when you when
you got a a deeper Dive In
you need those personalities there with
the dev asking interview type questions
do that there but when this when it
comes to this this format is the best
format we didn't have no high profile
execs I don't care for that
I don't want it you know I just really
want to know what these dudes is working
on and I want them to be proud about the
game and so it's a 10 out of 10 for me
when it comes to the format yeah oh one
thing I forgot to mention was I love the
Whiteboard uh graphics and stuff yeah we
always talk about how the devs are you
know they're brainstorming on the
Whiteboard or whatever so yeah I love
that fact that it jumped from whiteboard
to whiteboard that was cool I like that
yeah now I'm with it you know on the
stream I kind of said the same thing my
I look back at it again you know it was
phenomenal and from a format perspective
it was damn near perfect
um I love the production values I felt
they really respected the devs they had
an energy like the devs coming out the
tunnel yeah I like how they did it from
their Studio locations you know what I'm
saying like we live at the Bethesda you
know what I'm saying like it was it gave
you an energy like I felt in the
building yeah you could save it maybe
there's a slight overproduction but I
didn't mind it you know I didn't mind it
I really loved the Deep dive I love the
fact that you know the dev had his few
minutes but then on screen is just that
game and his commentary behind it that's
what I've always wanted from Xbox
because it was just too much like King
said hey guys and I don't want any of
that like I didn't want any of that
inside Xbox energy this was perfect I
think from my understanding this state
outsourced this whoever this company is
pay them continue to pay them because
they really did that man it was
phenomenal and I I thought that um the
other thing that surprised when I said
on the stream was that if I would even
been okay if they would have been like
their normal Yellow Game Pass
infomercial and on this bucket I would
have been okay and they didn't even do
that right and I thought you know what
it was tasteful because it was like it
was already known to be expected you
know what you see in here is going to be
in Game Pass and the reason why this let
me tell you why this was a 10 out of 10.
for the people who's like who don't
understand it the reason why is because
look coming into this journey I'm gonna
be 100 with you at it y'all know like
I'm not really a Minecraft guy like that
you know what I'm saying you know Forza
I understand turn tandem dudes we get it
but out of all of these games and we'll
get to Hi-Fi Rush which is surprising to
join probably I was looking for it for
Forza Ford's release date and maybe
redfall because of red for interest but
overall those games are probably about
to gaze that Carl would check for when
the format is excellent is when you have
me have interest in something I was kind
of lukewarm on and the way you show it
the way you it was produced I was like
you know what y'all did a good job
because now I'm even interested okay let
me see what's going on with this game
now because of how well y'all showed it
and that's the difference sometimes Xbox
has great games and then they don't do a
great job of actually advertising it
correctly so yeah that's where I was at
with it but I put your whole question
back on you
I feel like
this particular one they needed to do
this more often
um you know I I like the fact that I was
uh I like the production I like how it
was phrased I like how they used the
picture they promoted it was putting the
the date under it and like using it to
go from one like transitioning from one
to another like it's just like look like
whoever did this like yeah looks like
coffee
maybe incorrect if they said Outsource
whoever is responsible yeah I did a good
job keep using them continue
and it's just you know nothing against
you know the marketing and like Major
Nelson in them which is but
I feel like this is going to
get attention more of the people that's
actually watching because I felt like
the old thing was trying to go towards
people that doesn't really gain because
it's cringe-worthy you know they spent
too long on certain subjects but I feel
like this particular one
you're gonna get some people to watch
these but let's be right here the
majority of people watching these events
is US yeah are us our type of Gamers
influencers people who watch the
influencers you're not you're trying to
get people like my brother watching this
you know I'm saying like so I I like how
they stop trying to appease to these
people like you're going to get through
them with the trailers and and Word of
Mouth that's the biggest one word of
mouth and what I liked about this is
after this format was done and it
settled
I was like I wonder what the internet's
gonna say yeah I was curious yeah I went
to Twitter and besides the the typical
PlayStation does everything right play
Xbox does everything wrong
everyone was co-signing this and that
that's what I like like and I went to
the people that you know that are that
are truly on both sides you know
PlayStation fans that that like the Xbox
brand but they're just not happy with
the Xbox brand right now and even those
people I didn't see no like huge you
know back backlash or anything like that
for the most part it was if they did
have issues with it it was criticism it
was constructive criticism I didn't see
a whole lot of people just hating on
this game to hate on this game and I
think that's important yeah no format
format was key so um we're gonna get
into which we'll get into now the actual
game shown and the stealth trap what
were we doing let's get a high and rides
high five Rush
you've got the most hours sir if you've
uh damn near close to beating it so like
where are you at with it because I I
know your history is kind of similar to
mine right we we're not the rhythm game
guys right so where you at
when I saw this camera rolled my eyes
it looked impressive there but it's just
like this isn't something for me like I
don't like games that that demand like
excessive timing if that makes sense and
you can't get more excessive timing than
a rhythm game right because they demand
you to play the game to the rhythm of
whatever beat that they're playing uh
but when I played it because I was
playing a fire emblem and you know Cog
was like uh addict I know you don't like
it I don't know you don't like these
type of games I'ma need you to play the
first boss at least that's like I said
it's like you're in the same pocket I
don't like rhythm-based games generally
either so I was worried out one drop or
continue I'm sorry mm-hmm yeah but he's
like he's all right so you know
if someone said come on attic just admit
that you got no room
don't you do that
so I played the first one I played the
uh the the
I like just the energy the game gives
and it doesn't demand
that you have like correct certain
timing it just encourages it and what's
funny is you there's like multiple forms
of timing in this game it's not just
regular time you have the timing to the
beat and you have timing to successfully
use combos performing combos I didn't
care about the time to the beat that
music don't exist that beat don't exist
to me the only thing I care about is to
make sure that I do the correct
sequences to pop them off
so it it is you know I I like it man I I
think this is the best game that Xbox
has made in quite a bit of time and uh
you know when you see stuff like this it
really makes me think
yo they these Studios do need to be
working on something to the side like
always I'm coming around or passion
project this is big for you this is
something something as small as as this
type of game like look I'm okay because
I wasn't a big fan of pinnamon because
uh it just wasn't my cup of tea I'm okay
with companies get a try Panda but if if
other companies like Tango gets to try
Hi-Fi rush because it's like you know
when you give these people the creative
Outlet to work on stuff that they want
to work at because if you look at this
game
no one here would be thinking this is a
Tango game it just it's something that
they don't make yeah they generally make
more horror type of games like you know
the evil withins so when you look at
something like this it doesn't look like
the type of game they make at all
Studios that's crazy yeah good and for
and they nailed it like they people said
oh this game's not 88 or 87 no it's a 90
Plus game
like this game is is fluid this game has
character when you play this that no
stages alike it's not like I don't like
clear room go to room clear room Gold
Room it has that but it's different it's
like one map you're trying to drain
money from a certain individual one map
you're trying to do a lot of platforming
like and know one thing is the same they
change it up every stage
art style is good yeah you know what's
funny is it
it's got cringe-worthy dialogue but it's
intentional it's not like for spoken
where they try to be a serious tone
character like they want this dude to be
cringe-worthy because it it it adds to
the story
so it's good and you know not to mention
like this might got some of the best
boss fights I've seen in games in a
while
it's it's got from software normally
does two-phase fights yeah sometimes
three but most the time too where you
get them halfway and the change is up
these most the time they change these
fights up three to four times like
you'll be sitting there uh there's a
character where you're like you're
fighting them and then after you do
enough damage they pull like they pull
like a metal rod off the wall and they
start electrocuting themselves to attack
you with it so it it's like I like when
you change things up like that and it's
it's good man it's good it's like I said
this this is definitely the best game
Microsoft has come out of their camp in
the past couple years easy like easily
the past couple years no doubt yeah big
big one
um uh solve King everyone wants to jump
in left next on the high five
well I will say that I have again I
haven't played it yet but so I'll give
my initial reactions upon seeing it and
I'm kind of in the in the same boat as
addict when I saw it I rolled my eyes
but I rolled my eyes
because I was like oh man here's the
game the the PlayStation boy is gonna
come for us and the cartoony Xbox games
never doing something like you know
that's grounded and looks on the level
so I'm like here we go but just
immediately looking at it I was like oh
no his here's the janitors passion
project you know you know actually let
me say something real quick so someone
just put in the chat
these people
should have made battle tones
like some kind of art style and I felt
like they could have took the gameplay
in a good direction it's just
I actually do feel like Tango was one of
the lower echelons there was nothing
wrong with Battletoads
for old dead franchise you know you go
back and look at that old dead franchise
it can't hold the candle to what the new
one looks like so all that Nostalgia you
want the old one go play the old one
there's nothing I don't like the old one
the old one sucks but yeah so when it
comes to like I will say that Tango has
become like a way more diverse studio
now to me yeah they definitely roll
continue so yeah so there it's again
immediately I got like bleeding edge
Vibes I was like No And I was like no no
please and again bleeding is has this
positive stuff no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
so but then it continued to watch it I'm
like oh this looks like it seems like
it's more robust than what I initially
thought and obviously it was the art
style from it I enjoyed the art style
from the rip I just I I was just
thinking about the reactions to it right
and I'm like it's a lot of Sega and
Dreamcast energy in this video Jet Set
Radio
um even some Ratchet and Clank stuff
with how the combat is with the you know
I'm smacking people around with the
guitar and stuff like that and then when
the when they said the Rhythm aspect
wasn't it wasn't so tightly knit that
you could you could just play the game
if you want and you could have fun or
you could really follow a rhythm stuff
and be rewarded for it I was like yes
they didn't lock people in in analyze
exactly and and so now the game is
immediately appealing to a vast number
of people who maybe don't like Rhythm
games
everything about it the shadow drop of
it the fact that nobody knew this was
coming obviously it got leaked a little
bit you know a little bit earlier but at
the end of the day I didn't even see
that energy
yeah I did like the day before I think
it was but if if you look at the stream
when we said it I was surprised that
Tango was even there
okay I didn't even see the leaks at all
yeah so again but both for the most part
they held on they held it close to the
chest very well yeah uh but to see the
energy behind it to see that being Xbox
Japanese first party energy I was like
wow this is something and for it to be
received that way I was just I was I'm
super excited to get down and play
because again Sega kid it has all of
that energy that is the energy that I
want from Japan that is the type of
energy where they they bring a little
bit of weird they bring the anime style
where it looks kind of like uh
spider-verse a little bit yes um it
looks beautiful Jet Set Ray
again everything about that when I
settled in and really took a look at it
I was like wow they did this perfectly
and for me it just spoke to a little bit
of like the confidence I felt they had
in this overall presentation I was like
oh they they're confident they this
wasn't something they took lightly and
they it seems like they knew that this
Shadow drop of this game and the quality
of the game that they had here was
something they could get away with and
would be successful because to me you
Shadow drop it you get if you get if you
get a bum reaction from the beginning
then everybody who watched it you know
how you know how the discourse happens
all of a sudden there's a wave of
negativity and nobody knows anything
here the wave was positive and when
people finally got a chance to play it
it would just supported that initial
wave and then all of a sudden now
everybody who was watching so we talk
about how it was a missed opportunity to
maybe talk about this at the game awards
right because all eyes were on it
factual but if you think about it an
Xbox Centric thing the people who love
Xbox are watching it right so that's for
them right the people who make it their
point to hate on Xbox probably watching
as well right so right the only people
who aren't watching or people who are
who are just not Xbox people and I don't
mean like in a yeah in a sort of
derogatory way I don't mean it like
really hate I just mess with with
PlayStation or I just met with it but I
don't care about the discourse around it
I just like my One console right so
there's no negativity around you know
why they would watch or wouldn't watch
so you got plenty of eyes on this and
then when the discourse around it is
objectively now this is good like this
is good if it's good to great yeah um
it's just it's killing it right now it's
it's the wave man like then they did you
see the um Benji sales very impressed
high five Rush as the chart is ranked by
revenue and high five Rush is only
thirty dollars and yeah high five Rush
at 30 actually made more Revenue launch
week than for spoken did that
you know what exactly and in game pass
on PC I think a lot of those words
training on Twitter let me ask you this
I just to flip it because I know King's
smiling and turning I know he's like
yeah they see I get normal right there
but the thing I was gonna say is like do
you think us as gamers are getting it
wrong with what they should be doing
when advertising when they literally do
a shadow drop no advertising the game
ends up you know playing phenomenal the
words of mouth gets out and then they
get the expected result 10-fold you know
what I'm saying is it is it like
marketing has changed now and it's just
the virality of how something can take
off is really what's moving out here as
opposed to yo you need to do a Super
Bowl ladder you need to do uh whatever
ad right but I was uh when I worked at
this network I sat in a lot of like
because they they would they would
encourage their employees to sit on like
uh their advertising meetings and stuff
and I always did it because I it got me
off the phones
absolutely you know um pretty much like
a lot of the advertising companies
they're going away from advertising on
TV in a lot of different ways the only
thing that they really advertise is like
big big shows like you know with The
Walking Dead used to be which you know
there's not even really those shows on
cable television anymore like the
majority of the big shows are on a
streaming platform for the most part and
like something like the Super Bowl or
the NBA games or you know uh they didn't
really talk about hockey but I don't
know anything about that but you know I
I think
my I think people see their money better
spent going to streamers going to
influencers because they're targeting
the audience that they generally think
is going to buy their games
but I don't think that that means you
shouldn't promote I just think that
means you know you got to promote more
cleverly like you know Sony does with
making the uh the subway system look
like Spider-Man or horizon or God of War
like like the amount of people in New
York that get on the subway train is
insane like I'm sure that cost you a lot
of money but I'm sure millions of people
saw your product and I don't think that
they should not advertise but I do feel
like they need to be more strategic
advertising and they also just need to
advertise like certain games more like I
honestly truly feel like the reason
Microsoft doesn't advertised to the
foolish degrees because let's be real
here they really haven't had much to
advertise right you know and but when
they do have a console advertise or big
games like Halo they do advertise those
things but the thing is is we can't we
got to be careful with the advertising
because realistically like in terms of
like first party games they've been very
light you you see them advertise game
pass because that's really average you
know that's really easy to advertise but
they don't really have a whole lot of
games to advertise now once we start
seeing these other games pop out I'd be
surprised if we don't see them picking
up on Advertising but until that is I I
can't really speak on the marketing that
much so I'll finish your point and then
okay no no I I I kind of agree with
addict in that regard where it's like
it's it's so different now when you look
at this I think I talked about this when
we talked about Starfield and you know
where you know what what if we lived in
a world where Starfield kind of got
announced the way Fallout 4 did and it's
like here it is you didn't know it was
coming
um see you in six months is out right
whoa what would this course around the
game be if that were the case right and
we didn't know about Starfield at this
point and maybe found out about
Starfield this coming E3 or something
like that
um
so when you look at it it is that thing
of obviously the game has to be good
yeah
the game isn't good it's all going to
blow up in your face you know what they
did the shadow drop
disarms haters yes because you can't it
takes Everybody by support because
because here's the thing not saying that
they should do it for everything but uh
sorry to apologize to cut you but when
you let's say you were questioned like
even me like I don't know if I like
Rhythm gang I don't know if I'm gonna
lie it's beautiful as it looked right
but when you say yo right now and then
to King's Point Game Pass
right ain't no excuse right ain't no
excuse me and you're getting your touch
on and you like yo this is crazy right
you know what what I love about the
shadow drop too that it was a shadow
drop for press as well yes
nobody had it early nobody
it wasn't like whatsoever it wasn't just
a random Flux Of reviews that popped out
like and that's how they have to do
things because who you think be leaking
after this stuff that means exactly
exactly so and now you have you have
like a pure discourse around it because
nobody no you could not change anybody's
opinion early everybody had to get their
opinions at the same time yeah I love
that man I love that do more of this do
more of this with bigger games I would
love to see this so yeah I feel Sunny
ain't gonna do that interview everything
like that but this is picking all the
studios that they're working with I do
think you'll see the shadow drop more
than people think yeah it makes sense it
won't be everything they do or every
title but I think smaller indie games
that need that oh that's what I mean
yeah that's what I mean like they're all
these smaller teams that especially you
know you you see stuff like grounded you
know pendant you know regardless how you
feel about that game you know a lot of
people love that game but rated High
then you got games uh like you know high
five rush like these these smaller
double a type of games like they can
easily succeed yeah there we go that's
good keeping patient okay we've been
waiting to get his balls off let me hear
that I told your souls let me hear where
it's going
no it's just the fact that um Game Pass
had to be uh an established platform and
from that business model you can disarm
a ton of uh individuals you can disarm
the people that's leaking the game
information out you can disarm um a lot
of the haters you can disarm Metacritic
because
as much as you guys
say that Metacritic doesn't uh formulate
how you play games it's a large
contendant that run with those numbers
factually and play games based on
numbers because they think that a game
that's in the 90s more people plays it
so they're in with the In Crowd opposed
to a game that you know got a 60 because
I'm pretty sure there's somebody out
there that loves for spoken it's like I
don't know what the hell they talking
about this is worth every last bit of my
seventy dollars and that's that leads to
the whole I don't like
um people to tell me how my food tastes
right so
when when we're watching the show and
that game pops up first yet
you know somebody's passion project
right right and you you say to yourself
please God don't let it be uh bleeding
edge but see bleeding edge wasn't a bad
game not at all the problems with
bleeding edge was I think it needed more
time to cook because when it came to the
personality of the game the music of the
game the Aesthetics of the game
everything looked perfect it was just
missing some gameplay elements that I
thought that could take it to the next
level and if it had more time to cook in
the cooker it would have been so
um but one of those games it's one of
those stories so everything has to hit
in this rare occasion
this one game comes out and it hits
because visually it's nostalgic
audio wise it had known bands right so
you can play it in streamer mode it's
huge yeah
right so they say you know so you don't
get monetized uh demonetized what we do
is you can put in streamer mode and you
can play all our original music opposed
to playing copyrighted music dope
huge it it plays well on an X and A
Series S nobody's talking about that
that this game looks visually stunning
on both platforms and my my initial
thought process was how is the traversal
because Jet Set Radio traversal was you
must keep
going from uh from surface to surface
surface the surface grinding and keeping
your momentum going
Sunset Overdrive is pretty much the same
way like to get around the city and it's
a it's a free-flowing thing
when I got to this game it wasn't that
to my surprise it was a platformer at
heart it was a regular beat em up
platformer with different elements that
they put in with a rhythm-based tune to
it and the animations the character
somebody said I forgot who said that uh
he reminds him of Peter Parker
um
he did remind me of the kid from Queens
yeah you know uh just young uh Whimsical
jokesy uh I like when the cat shows up
yeah and they actually Bond it was so
many different things and the world
looks so alive so many colors
I like it the place is is jumping so
there's no reason there's no reason for
like somebody to see you having fun with
it and then throw shade right I I hear
that and I know
that's a financial thing right
but
I'm here to tell you
Xbox has partnered with Samsung
LG and you can play it on your phone all
you have to do is bend the knee
and get Game Pass right and then for the
15 you can go and play one of the
hottest games right now so a lot of
times people say a shield for Xbox I
don't get a check
but what I'm doing is I'm giving you
an option and removing the barriers that
you're putting in your own brain because
I saw some people
tapping on the show
when it wasn't necessary right they did
something good give them their big UPS
or don't say nothing at all you don't
gotta you don't got to say anything um
the game is good let's rock let's have a
good time and I like to see more stream
of streaming I really would like to see
attic playing this game streaming it
yeah not salute absolutely well said um
ain't got much to add but it's like now
I gotta look at like addict said I gotta
look at Tango different now
we heard tiger was down we like yo they
got a Japanese Studio that's dope we
know them for what is it even with the
end and you know
he's the legend from Ghost Wire yeah
obviously evil the legend right so
that's the pocket we got them in you
know what I'm saying they come out and
not only this joint
fire like the Polish of this game that
means like Gorilla Games they were
sitting on this sitting on this they
literally had this entire during the
game points even I during the game
awards they've been sitting on this game
with all the slander they've been
getting no games you have nothing to
talk like and then it leads me to field
interview because Phil says we already
have stuff planned for now and it's a
Philadelphia with RJ as well as the um
the what you call it the the E3 quote
unquote version of the Showcase so it's
just interesting to me that they took
that knowing they had stuff on top then
the game comes out unless we just got to
call it what it is like you know you
could say it may not be for you or
whatever whatever but like the consensus
is this is a great game they broke the
internet we see the user scores the
Metacritic slowly coming up right now
we're seeing more reviews coming up I
think it's like an 88 or whatever right
now they're in the conversation people
are saying yo this is is a Vibe me
personally like it was the reason why I
enjoyed the way they did this the way
they handled it is because one of my
major beats with Xbox you know how I
feel about this song where it's like
I get set of the expectation right I get
being realistic
yeah like the difference between
Nintendo and Sony everybody else is that
they know how to do the magic moment
when you go oh my God we didn't see it
it's coming like yo that's crazy that
grow big crying oh my God this is the
Sony joint of Dreams oh my God Nintendo
do so y'all smashed it blah blah that's
what Xbox has always lacked to me that
flare this is what I'm talking about you
sit there and you say we sit there we
looking at the game I'm like yo that
look that look fire right I look like
Sunset Jet Set Radio and blue Legend had
a baby and this character looked this
whole animation when they went from
seamless cartoon animated Game to cinema
I'm like yo that's different
then they like you're right they could
have told me end of the year I'd have
been going yeah cool you know what I'm
saying fall is gonna be lit with this
they ain't gonna go right now wait a
second is it almost a thousand people in
here I only got 400.00
sure we got that many in here
y'all not saving these endangered
animals we'll be trying to save platypus
button what's going on we dropping bars
in here anyway no 936 of y'all not hit
the like button thank you for hit the
like button thank you sir thank you so
look and and ladies and um so look again
when you do that that's that Nintendo
switch energy ask that PlayStation
energy when you go wow what a start to
the year this is a phenomenal so they
started with
um a monster hunter rise golden eye now
listen it's a fantastic it's a fantastic
look I just want to address
um you know Phil's comments real quick
about it and he just said you know glad
that he mentioned pentament he said I
see these games being a pair because of
smaller projects from larger novellas
object of large developers I'm just
wondering how successful the question
was how these products would have been
for you and whether you see them fitting
in the ecosystem and then pretty much he
goes into saying like creating that
creative Outlet gazing successes fan
internally he loves to give the the
outlet to creators and opportunities and
see this is the positive now about the
hands the quote unquote the hands off so
to speak because you allow them to
create what they want to create and we
had Gene Park on where he interviewed
Neil druckman and Neil druckman said
this with Noida he's like one of the
best things developing you come up with
some of your best things when you are
actually passionate and allowed to make
what you want but sometimes you're
you're shoveled or boxed in to just
being formulate like remember we had
Jason Rubin on right Jason Rubin as much
as he's the OG naughty dog he did crash
he did you know Jackson Dexter after a
while the success became so busy that it
overwhelms you and now you feel forced
that you have to keep creating those
type of things instead of doing what you
want and then that kind of broke him out
got it at the game he passes the
football to deal they do Uncharted but
after a while he's like bro I gotta you
know we'll do something else here come
last of us so there is a positive to
this Mo this whole style absolutely with
it we know that negative aspect oh we
understand yo three four three they may
need a little hand holding on their
situation but to everyone else that this
is what we hear when they were acquired
we love that we have this opportunity
you know what I'm saying and we have the
reasons who knows people say I hear the
other kind of like well this game
existed before and it's not like they
should get credit but it may not have
come out because they wouldn't have had
the financial backing to support it and
get it out so that's the thing you got
to look at the the thing about
acquisition the positive about it in
this case
yeah let's go this is the only place
that these dudes get to do this when it
comes to Xbox
I get that Holy place they get to say oh
well look that game don't count as an
Xbox game
I feel you I don't I don't get into the
purest talk yeah
when they come out and where it come out
is all that matters the finished product
is all that matters all that Purity yo
you wasn't back there in 88 it doesn't
matter no one cares cause guess what
when the game come out you playing it
you're having fun you're not sitting
there looking at the release timing
window of the first dev kit you don't
care about that so that's that's the
people was looking for I can't enjoy
myself yeah they take away Joy that's
all that is let's give it a buck no
one's sitting there looking at that
stuff so at the end of the day great job
phenomenal job the way they handle that
phenomenal job Tangled and got up
through the Rises like this is amazing
and I can't wait to see what they got
next I see the smile on their faces oh
they were happy and I'm gonna say I
don't think everything should be a
shadow drop for them I think it should
be very select people with it because I
don't know if it's going to work for
everything I want them to Shadow drop
Starfield though
this is a shot though but I had to say
that but yeah that's all I got let's um
addict want to talk about the the feel
anybody talked about seeing the film
interview any comments on that yeah I I
watched it you know one thing I will say
is
Phil's always been humble when it comes
to stuff but when you come out there and
say yo
you know to a point I can understand the
criticism for 2022 we should have done
better we will do better clearly if he's
he said stuff like this before but it's
like he could have easily had just PR to
wear on that question but you know he
took ownership of the issue that's going
on he's like look like
you guys called it out and you know
we'll do better we should have had more
games but you know it is what it is but
that's why we're starting this year off
to a bank like it's like last year they
could easily have shown High uh Hi-Fi
Rush at the Video Game Awards they could
have easily been part of another show
but they wanted to start 2023 on their
terms and not other people's terms
absolutely so I have any comments on the
NFL interview I don't know if you caught
any of it yeah definitely I just you
know to me like like Alex said to me
that I always like when you sit down and
own up to the things that you've seen in
the community yeah he said it was on him
as any good ball should do you know you
you generally say that you know crap
rolls downhill but when you have a boss
that says no it's on me it's on me even
if every single detail is not on him
that's what you want that's what you
want to sort of Shield your your teams
from from all of that sort of scrutiny
and put it all on you
um so to me yeah this is something that
we we know Phil for that you know Phil
is it's always going to be that dude
um and acknowledging the fact that hey
you know last year was was light there's
no two ways about it it was light in in
games that can be compared one to one to
our competitors right you know things
like pentimen and stuff like that all of
those things
are our wonderful games but they're not
going to be for everybody and you need
those games to sort of stand toe-to-toe
you got to get you got to give him
credit uh Microsoft credit too because
nine times out of ten because we've done
interviews like this
Phil had an ideal of what the questions
he was going to get and he didn't tell
IGN no you can't ask me about 2022 no
you can't ask me if you just seen the
streets they on fire we ain't talking
about that oh you want to talk about
last of us we ain't talking about that
either he's like hit me like because I
guarantee you a lot of other people in
the industry and be like we ain't
talking about that we we're going to
talk about these four things that I want
us to talk about and we're going out the
back then but no they they let that and
you know she had some good questions
cat Bailey is serious and don't get it
twisted Microsoft could have easily have
influenced that that meaning the way
they would have wanted to do but they
didn't yeah and then obviously you know
having to take the hard questions about
34 3 and Halo right
um and to me it that situation is in a
state of flux there's only so much you
can say because again I think it is
evolving but I think that the reality of
is that they you know in order to the
great stewards of that franchise you're
gonna have to make some tough decisions
and you're going to have to see again I
when it comes to 343 and the quality of
what they've made
I've always said they know how to make
good halo apart from infinite generally
they've never been able to put it all
together in one product where an
infinite they did it's just that the
product that they enveloped it in
requires more right requires more
because of the type of product that
infinite is supposed to be but if you
look at infinite in a you know in a silo
and you and you say okay take up all the
all the free to play stuff and it's just
a regular Halo game as we've expected it
it's pretty damn good right we're just a
little bit short on maybe maps and stuff
like that single player content stuff
that we've seen in the past but as a
whole it is a good product yeah
through and through
so you know he you know he indicated
that some way shape or form 343 is going
to be involved in the future of Halo
what that becomes I don't think any of
them really know yet it's just going to
be a matter of of them sitting down and
figuring out what the best course of
action is for Halo on a lot of different
fronts so yeah the fact that he was able
to address it as best he could and and
and and indicate that yeah it's still
there's still more to do there
um I just I just like interviews like
that because again it's stuff that we
don't get from Nintendo we don't get it
from Sony I love to hear somebody talk
about their business man and I loved it
back in the day when Sean Layton would
talk about it when when you know Jack
Trenton would talk about it because
again you want to see gaming is unlike a
lot of hobbies and that is so mainstream
now
you need Personalities in order to
interface with the fans of it I don't
understand this going the other
direction for Nintendo and for Sony I
really don't but whatever that's what
they've chosen to do I love that
Microsoft does this I love that they you
know they've said you know what we're
going to be as transparent as we
possibly can be without giving away
everything that we're doing
um and and we're gonna go from there
we're gonna take the lumps we're going
to take them we're going to step on a
rake every now and again because they're
gonna do it
um but at the very least we feel we're
being as honest as we can be with our
base and we're doing our best to try to
get these games out uh it doesn't
behoove us to let you know every stumble
that happens in development because it
just makes it just creates negative
discourse that doesn't need to be there
and I think they're learning that more
and more so yeah I I like this I like
the interview I like the fact that Kat
Bailey was going to go in there and kind
of ask the tough question she's been in
Industry a long time and uh yeah I I
thought it was good are we going to talk
about the rest of the show I'll get your
balls off on that no real quick also
also real quick the rest of the show
right
um Again Minecraft Legends isn't
necessarily for me
um but again like I know that's gonna do
so well and I think the biggest thing is
that everything they showed here is of
quality yes everything they showed here
is of quality and it's going to do well
in its own spaces I think Forza
Motorsport the fact that it is so pretty
it has the buffer of Game Pass people
that are not car people are gonna look
at this like I gotta load this up and
see what this is right and the things
they talked about up about possibly
onboarding people that are more of a
novice in terms of car stuff is great
because that's always been the separator
right like Horizon is the game that
could bring everybody in let's figure
out how Forza can do it in a way that
doesn't diminish the hardcoreness of it
right and the game look ridiculous
obviously Red Ball Red Ball okay what
are we doing
to me everything that I was hoping from
the stuff we had heard about before they
showed a decent amount of it I think the
power stuff that I'm used to seeing in
in
um immersive Sim games
they're going to show more of that in
terms of you know skill trees and stuff
like that they're not going to show all
of that so that's something you're going
to really have to get from playing the
game advancing those skill trees and
seeing what powers you get and how you
can interact with the world with them
um I wasn't you know the dilute stuff
and the shooting stuff I know they made
that because this is the type of game it
is right but that sort of stuff doesn't
interest me as much as the manipulation
and the powers and how you utilize those
in order to create sort of uh these
gameplay experiences that you can't find
in any other sort of game but I was
super impressed with the way the game
looks the atmosphere but of it the uh
the art style everything that I've seen
so far is to me what I would like to see
in the evolution of an immersive Sim
game and an Arcane game I know Maddie
still on the fan
but but I'm excited for that and then
the other stuff that I don't play I
obviously Elder Scrolls Online that's
going to be huge man and like King said
they they took that they announced it
very surface level they let everybody
know hey if you haven't played you can
play everything now for free and then he
said stick around if you want to see the
Deep dive into what necron is and this
that and the other so again I I thought
it was great um now in terms of in terms
of speculation about dates and this that
and the other this is what I feel you're
gonna be mad at me Carl oh what are you
doing you'll be matter because I'm gonna
have to pull away a little bit from to
soft talk Sunday oh
what are we doing I would say this we
talked a little bit about how the
confidence that it seemed that they felt
and what they were showing off with the
Hi-Fi Rush sort of Shadow drop with the
quality of the stuff that they were
showing like they feel good about what's
going on right and they and they seem to
now be are beginning to understand the
power of the o-ish moment right
so I started thinking I'm like
they didn't give the date for this for
this star field then get the date for
the Starfield event what if what if
they're like oh you know Minecraft
Legends A4 but it's April that's late
man I spent the expected that early I
don't that Cadence feels weird to me so
I started to think I'm like you know
what it could well be that they're
awesome yeah we're gonna give them
another mic drop moment oh April's too
late Starfield late February March oh
you are the boss trade yeah okay anyway
March okay here you go it just just
because of the bottom of my God from
this just because of the vibe that I got
from this I'm like yo they feel they're
ready and they knew the power of that
shadow drop in the mic drop moment of
here's this game it's a quality game
it's a robust game it's not this tiny
game and you can play it now they they
saw the power of that going into that
for them to be like
see them being like you know what it's
ready for March okay
hey um you know this this coming week
this coming week we get the date the
date is sometime in February and it's
like yeah and and and in March let's go
um so I I I'm sorry oh but I got I got
to push a little bit away from soft talk
son I gotta join King okay okay gangster
listen Okay because it just I liked the
energy from them I like the confidence
station
I really did like if they if some if the
stuff they had showed have been a little
bit suspect and that's kind of why I
feel like I wasn't necessarily off put
by the lack of forces
I wasn't off but I was like I don't know
man there's something here so again
um it could very well still be you know
at the end of the year and whatever but
not that girl wants it not that [__] is
is saying it must exactly I'm
eliminating my ability
hey take your time amen thank you dude
come with these imaginary dates
yeah but again I just I'm liking the
energy I'm liking the confidence it
takes it it takes some confidence to put
out a game that's that stylized yes and
have faith that it's going to do well
and not backfire and blow up in your
face
um who did that for you and I like that
I like that I like that and I'm I'm a
Roller Kingdom oh okay
prisoner of the moment
it was everything else it was everything
else but it was it was that but that
really this is what they be talking
about when your heart don't pump cool
lady
his heart was purple Kool-Aid before
immediately
now that we got that washed out of his
blood again
but he here and what I like is when they
turn around
every now and then
they gotta walk away from that comments
I don't believe that no more so it so
happens that the game does get delayed I
have no right to say anything
I'll be ready
okay so so it feels comments in the
other games what you got
well Phil comments is Phil comments you
know he's he gave a nice interview after
a great show
um you know and
this they had to have a great show
because they had a a nice earnings call
oh you're talking about it yeah so the
airlines call was on the 24th which I
told people was on the 24th and there's
a reason why this show was going to be
on the 25th and um to wipe whatever bad
taste out of people's mouths because
they knew about the layoffs the week
okay okay so you have the layoffs the
week before you have the earning calls
to to butter up of the stock share
holders and the quell you guys down
because I don't have nobody talking
about nobody laid off now yeah
all that fake stuff oh honey and the
show's a 10 of a 10.
you gotta do that yeah they said yo I'ma
tell you right now I find Russians do
bomb baby
no more of the fake I'll cry
this is why I tell you guys you frauds
100 I look you straight yeah y'all don't
keep that same energy yeah yeah like a
goldfish or a dog I hate the sound that
thing makes I hate it sounds terrible
it's grinding on your pulse
sounds like something else
I don't know but I don't play with your
choice to get in here you better stop
but I'm saying this right so Phil and
then Phil goes on the promo talk about
the good you know dissipate the bad
mm-hmm and you know so I'm solve you
know comes over see this is what happens
when you start building up uh a brand
and faith in the public
that stealth drop was necessary right so
you know like if you're an artist
you know when that song that you write
in this heat
it's just all about who hears it how you
drop it and when it happens right
and they nailed it if they would have
did that at the game awards show
it wouldn't have hit the same
I don't care how many people have saw it
it wouldn't have hit the same because we
went in this show thinking only four
games are gonna be there
then y'all saw Tango games like
[Music]
you know what I like too King King said
that the studio wanted to drop uh
uh Shadow dropping yeah yeah so
it's it's having that belief in your
product and I tell you remember I always
tell you don't let your heart pump
Kool-Aid stand on your square and and if
you're gonna do it do a bowl if you're
gonna fail fail miserably right but if
you're going to succeed succeed with the
wind behind your back and your hands
flying and people can see you soaring
and what did they do
it's nothing you cannot deny
that dropping it over there on Jeff's
show would have been a detriment to this
show because you wouldn't have had
anything you would have had those same
four games that Aaron was like keep your
expectations low I gotta break protocol
let us play with each other's joysticks
with the five dollar Super Chat my heart
pumps Kool-Aid for song and I want him
to pump something out for me
[Laughter]
with each others he changed his name for
this I told you to relax with the
comments about what you thought wow
share
again
Phil is doing exactly what he's supposed
to do all this stuff is strategic right
and then you're going into the now it's
like are they going to keep this format
is this format good right they know the
format is good if they deviate from this
format then that's all on them yeah
right if if if you go and you purposely
step on a rig like Sovereign says this
is all on you you got all a good will
and you've done this before haven't we
seen them have all the Good Will in
order just to sputter it out at the end
of the year they did it with star Phil
and redfall they had all the Goodwill
throughout the year and then
fellas did they face at the finish line
and couldn't get across it so I I hear
you guys starting off nice
uh Monster Hunter rise yeah you know all
these games y'all had high on life y'all
y'all been riding since high on life to
be honest with you then you have another
Hi-Fi you know a game with high in it
high five rush and I would say that this
game is getting a lot more CR uh more
praise than I in life did hot life got a
lot I forgot about Ohio life already
yeah
my thoughts behind on life is the bad
language that is a barrier you know to
really promoting it so but this game
doesn't have that this game is uh adult
because the skill level if they have
adult and you know child level you know
so it's pretty for kids to play and it's
you know the skill levels for adults but
anyway
um the interview is fantastic the rest
of the show is incredible you know the
only problem I have again is Forza and
um if you don't miss if you don't hit
your dates
they put their date out there sir what's
up like I said chess out
I think they're still looking at how
other things drop because they do have
more games in Tuck that they want to do
stealth drops and some certain big
titles can't do that so you you might
have oh March
well you might have yeah you have to be
strategic
but but but you have to also Okay so
the strategy that they use with dropping
these games now right it's always
strategy they're not running from nobody
you know how how high five Rush showed
you that they don't they swing first
like they bomb first they don't care
like they don't we don't gotta Market we
got them you understand you going good
over here because the product is good
when the product is good you gonna buy
you don't have to worry about going to
terrestrial television terrestrial
television is dead
all right so somebody did a tick tock of
it and it goes crazy it gets in somebody
else's hand on Tick Tock and it goes
crazy and then it goes to uh YouTube
shorts and it goes crazy then you got
the guys on Twitter and it goes crazy
nobody cares about regular TV and some
Super Bowl ad everybody's not watching
anyway so those days are dead Microsoft
has the wave
this is why one guy looked over and said
I don't like the fun they have him
when you watch your shows you watch with
your wallet
my wallet was Sleek when I was watching
this show and it didn't have to wake up
because my bill was paid for a game pass
so all the stuff that was coming through
on Game Pass was uh it's like a freebie
it's like a bonus so
you can't get high five rush to drop
inside PS plus because Jim wants that
bread until those philosophies change
that's when the hata change so when on
your side y'all have the same fun
because you're not having fun you're
looking over like why is not happening
here but you're not vocalizing it in
that manner you're vocalizing is hate
but really it's self-hate because it's
really you hate your platform for not
doing what the other platform is doing
and so you have to say oh that doesn't
look good or Game Pass is a cancer to
all games but if Sony was doing it on
their side it would be a boom for the
industry there is another win for Sony
it's all financially based cause of for
the hate
look over there see how it could be done
vocalize your hate outwardly towards
Sony and let them know stop going over
there talking about we don't got games
and Microsoft is doing this at the third
stop snitching and start getting those
games inside Game Pass I mean inside of
PlayStation Plus you can't get smoking
look oh try to keep it quick as possible
um yeah look it was the stealth drop was
definitely something that because of
Game Pass even if you're on the fence
about it right like even if you're like
yo I don't know 70 I don't know but if
that eliminates the army so I'll give
you that I will push back on the uh game
award stuff you know based on the
audience you know I mean I still feel
that there is a huge audience that will
never listen to an Xbox direct and if
they if they if you have it on the
biggest platform look overall it was the
right call I'm with y'all that the right
call was to probably make your show
popping like attic is always saying
and to do it I still just wish they
would have showed something at the game
yeah
like something small based on the year
that they had in 2022 I am not forgiving
them for that that's just me where I'm
at but
you know in hindsight and you look at
this now yes this was phenomenal I'm not
going to take away any of that I will
say it definitely does help but the game
is quality and when the game is great
and Polished it's good it's really good
oh it makes a difference and that's what
I always tell people like at the end of
the day that's why y'all call it soft
talk or whatever y'all call it I'm
calling it quality talk now because when
it's quality man it's just you see it
look at the talk people are like yo this
is a potential Game of the Year notice
when the game hits everyone shuts off
yeah that's what I tell people that's
why all the delay stuff does not bother
me because I see what this does the Good
Games Shut people up they got nothing
else to say but make excuses or oh I
don't like it or whatever whatever but
if the masses accepted it's gonna be on
your timeline in your face annoying you
that everyone else is having fun except
you so that's just where I look at it
yeah
and you know if Microsoft isn't on the
phone Tango it's like that uh you know
that second that second team yeah what
you need for another one you could
potentially have a franchise and a
mascot in the face that I would play
yeah like a face of the joint they even
talk about 808 the cat whatever maybe I
keep it quick Forza looked phenomenal
you know obviously turn 10 do what turn
ten do ray tracing and track attack
track they've been those dudes I'm not
worried about it you know obviously they
didn't drop their release date so look
give them time I I don't care about that
like if you need to come out in the
second half because you need to polish
up polish up it does not bother me
um red form with soft it looked great
I'm still in the same pocket as I would
I love my only issue with with the Drake
prior was that I never felt I was in
fear because the way they was playing it
they was just dominating all the
vampires so to me when I seen them do
that Titanfall down of a boss and he was
coming with the The Rook oh yeah
I want that oh yo what are we gonna do
with this type of situation that's what
I need to see I like the unique
abilities apparently there's going to be
extra characters in the season pass
we'll see how that go but um yeah man
look
it was it was a great show my rating for
the show remember the difference between
rating the format and reading this show
by waiting for the show was eight out of
ten you know what I'm saying because
eight because it's a high rating for me
considering a lot of the games I
initially came in not that interested in
and then boom you do that and you have a
stump drop you did that thing as far as
Phil's comments you know look he owned
it which we expected to he's always a g
in that respect as far as Odin what
happens and stuff like that I am curious
to see what 343 actually does he said
he's gonna leave that to the studio as
far as when they're ready to announce
what they're gonna do I'm curious
whether or not they stay with it whether
it's on to the next whatever that but to
me the thing that really surprised me
was the Activision Blizzard top
and still on his square like yo
confident more confident than ever that
this is going to get done and the thing
that's interested in me remember because
again shout out wait first of all get
better because we miss you we need you
we need you to really break this stuff
down in the way it needed to be broken
because I'm not speculating anymore on
all the news that comes right it's just
too much and it's he says he say one
week this side look like it's with it
next side who knows right people on
planes doing it I don't know what's
going on all I will say
is that Phil is stating that he is
extremely confident based on what has
happened so far
if they are able to close this deal
somehow
and you have that injection of games
that we think is coming right the stall
Fields the the forces you already got a
strong first half already the redfall
the Mind Minecraft you know what I'm
saying you already start to develop a
nice Cadence we know about the game pass
addictions if you're able to close
oh boy now we could talk about a
different conversation where it goes
from Yo Xbox is going to have games in a
solid year
to oh this could be one of them yes like
a potential season of you know year of
dreams you know that kind of thing with
grown men crying in the streets they got
Call of Duty and gay pass that's
anything you're not that I care about
Colby like that but a lot of people do
right and you now you start oh wow that
means Diablo could be
it gets different now you start the the
Pieces come together and what started as
potentially like yo what's going on with
Xbox and they come up with a few a fully
quarter fully fledged lineup man it
could get scary with the onslaught so
let's see what happens now pretty much
all I got on that anybody got anything
else before doing no cool I was gonna
combine because the Dead Space right on
this if you don't mind just because the
majority of us did not get a chance you
know saying to rock but just the early
Impressions you know it seems very
strong you know attic your desk face guy
you intent I know how far Rush had you
right now but do you intend to rock out
what Dead Space
um
eventually like at this point that's
probably one of those games like the
backlog at like the end of the year or
something because if you really think
about it like I'm not gonna really have
time to go back to that you know what
I'm saying like
so it might be a mess for you yeah and
it's something about the quality of the
game it's just it's like always say like
look like you could put as much as you
want out and Game Pass and stuff like
people only have a certain amount of
time to play certain amount of games a
month no I get that it's a lot of games
for sure for sure because I I would say
that
by the end of the day I'll have a high
high life beat so okay no doubt no doubt
solve literally your topic but um
something that you seem very interested
the ratings seem good people seem to be
popping with a dead space remake man
yeah I'm gonna touch base too I love
that game I just thought that it took
you know King and I had this debate
before but it just it took a lot of the
things that early Resident Evil games
did glow in the dark and it applied it
in a way where this is the game that
came after Resident Evil 4 right so
Resident Evil 4 for some people it's was
able to walk that line of like you still
have horror elements that work but it
was more action-y but the horror came
more from the tension of all of these
enemies coming at you at once in a way
that didn't happen in the old games
whereas Dead Space took some of that put
you back in into an enclosed environment
and then try to go back to the true sort
of the horror of it of like jump scares
and you know crazy the environments that
are small and but wow giving you the
better control than a Resident Evil 4 so
now you were empowered but they were
still finding ways to scare you right so
I think that's what dead space does
really well and
I like the fact that they brought this
game back largely kind of untouched but
at the same time
yeah I could say I'm a little bit
disappointed that it's it's kind of safe
in that way I would have liked to seen
them do something in the vein of
Resident Evil 2 remake of Resident Evil
3. um but those games are vastly
different games what they did with them
they brought them forward whereas Dead
Space the old one still failed the
original one still feels like a modern
game in a lot of ways
I agree with you on you know they could
have made some they did make changes to
a point I was told they made it a little
more open world in a way or it's not
like like think of like the the from
software games where it in sense it's an
open world for the most part because
they they create shortcuts to take you
back to previous sections like you know
Dead Space used to be like a corridor to
Corridor kind of thing where you do
chapter one it takes you to chapter two
and you can't really go back to chapter
one but the way it's been described to
me is like they've kind of opened it up
there and now you get to a certain part
of the game you can go back to previous
parts of the map so yeah it's I I think
that I'm okay with this because it's
going to encourage you know older fans
to play it's it's brought it to a place
where I would say it's definitely
meeting standards of gaming today right
so you could play it now and then you
know with with that much maybe you could
start a Dead Space 4 with a Dead Space 2
remake at the same time because you
clearly see that there is interest if it
sells well that they could easily make
their money back just off dead space too
yeah and that that that's what what I'm
about it's like you know bring this game
back in a good way to show people it's
still around but also give us something
that isn't the same like you know that's
why I said like a dead space four or do
what you want like you know if you want
to re if you want to redo it or
something or or use Isaac as a character
but it's not dead space I don't know but
yeah I think it this is the if you want
to bring the IP back make it relevant to
the people who loved it in the past and
then make it appealing to somebody who's
never played it before this is the way
you do it because the game is beautiful
the game is beautiful and what they've
done to change it up for uh for old
players is that what they have now is
like a horror like an AI director or A
Hard director which basically if you
played this game a lot of times you kind
of know where the the closets are the
monster closets are and the jump scares
are so they have something that that
changes that and changes the intensity
of of the amount of like enemies that'll
pop up in certain areas areas where you
think a certain enemy is going to pop up
it won't happen so it changes it up in
that way to sort of change the
experience
um it also is very dependent on
atmosphere and Ambiance like the the
sounds and the sound and the sort of the
sound direction of the game is super
important to it making you feel scared
um and from what I've seen of this
they've done an excellent job of even
making that a bigger deal in this
version of the game so to me it's yeah
is it is it quote unquote safe in some
ways absolutely but I do think it is a
good way to hopefully reintroduce it to
to people that loved it in the past and
to people who may want to move forward
because I would like to see them move
forward Dead Space it's been dead for
too long
um so I like this but again it it is not
what it is not on the caliber of
Resident Evil 2 remake okay
um oh kind of even what and and again
that's not to disparage it at all but
again that that level of remake of
taking it Taking technically what it is
and sort of turning it into something
else completely while sort of staying
true to what it was this isn't really
that this is more of a direct sort of
remake it seem like some people some
people wanted that people really seem to
be positive with the impressions as far
as so is it a remake or a remaster what
no no no no from the ground up it's
definitely built from the ground up
computer where you look at it it's it's
remade but they don't deviate a lot from
from the Beats of the original game
story wise and stuff like that again
they do certain stuff like addicts that
to expand upon it right um but it is
uh it's not a beat for beat remake like
what they call The Last of Us Part One
which is more beat for beat it just
feels a little more cinematic and it's
prettier this expands a little bit upon
that especially with the options like I
talked about how to change up the AI and
stuff like that
um but built from the ground up
graphically like when you if you're able
to implement like Ray tracing and all
this stuff in this game it's a gorgeous
game like it is very much a modern game
I'm sorry I think you can argue that we
have Capcom and Square Enix for for Dead
Space I feel like the success of Final
Fantasy VII remake and uh Resident Evil
2 was such enough for these other
companies so I was like look like people
will show up to the store in masses to
buy these type of games but we got to do
it right we can't just do it half and
then expect people to show up like we
gotta actually rebuild these games yeah
yeah kidding would be anything you'd be
interested in Dead Space well
um the thing with it is uh I brought one
and two before
um never finished them so amazing yeah
really okay there's always something
that comes out
so right now you know this comes out and
guess what
high five comes out it's always
something and it's like okay I'll get to
it before back in the days
when when
you don't really pay it any mind you get
into this cult-like habit of I gotta get
it first I got to get it that day like
you have to pick it up to be part of
some some group some some fake group
nobody cares bro if you copped or not we
are selfish as Gamers I'm playing what I
won't play first I don't care I'm
playing my stuff I don't care if you
went to the store and did whatever
that's your business right for sure it's
my system I'll put it what I want let's
go continue again if we wait and we're
we're patient with things uh especially
right now in this economy how it's going
game of dropping price and you'll pick
it up when you have the time A lot of
times what happens is I get these games
when they're on sale now like I'll see
them in the store and I'm like oh they
got an 80 off on that game like uh uh
Phoenix Rising I was like yo I wanted to
play that but when it came out it came
out around a time where was so many
other things that was playing then I
jumped into Elder ring and wiped that
game away so now it's it's just it fell
at a wrong time it's not something that
I'm gonna prioritize over anything else
at this moment and probably I can double
back and get it probably to be released
in a PlayStation Plus service I can
check it out or probably it'll come to
Xbox service and I can check it out but
other than that now I'm not not nothing
I'm running out for I'm not one of those
uh Dead Space heads
yeah no look I mean this was I I got I
always judge the quality of it by like I
look at um Maddie like Maddie's such a
dead space guy and he was worried
initially that he might have had it he
was just like yo I don't know if they
don't stinky Patrol they gonna do XYZ
then it was like a controversy when the
face picture came out and your man would
look like Peter Parker so this is the
funny thing is that the the voice actor
right that you brought back because
Isaac didn't speak in the original first
game he did speak in the in the in two
and three they decided to add speech to
the first to the remake of the first one
now and what they did was the voice
actor is playing the role now but it's
it's off-putting because the face looks
totally different to what the original
one was and you barely saw the original
one he put on the mask and you and even
in this one I think it's the same thing
you don't see it but when you do see it
you're like that's not Isaac but they
just like thankfully it's not a lot of
seeds with that or whatever yeah look
you know look they did that you know I'm
hearing extremely positive to the point
where where like people like yo we need
that space too because a lot of people
have loved Dead Space 2 is their first
one a lot of people think that's the
best one yeah so now it's like including
my brother it's literally could be a a
cash grab I want to give EA this though
before I finish
they've been we got to give yay some
flowers that they've been in their bag
lately with this single player and the
quality game stuff like like I know they
probably thank Vince for that too yeah
because the crew like they literally you
know you got that obviously you got the
Jedi joint you know I'm saying like this
they're getting into a pocket obviously
your man what's his name Joseph Ferris
in his games you know what I'm saying it
takes two they look I gotta be yeah I
was checking this girl though but
they're getting over here on the chat
but at the end of the day it was just
like yo like you know that is really
impressive that they are allowing these
things you know I'm saying that kind of
thing and look like that space is going
to be in a bag but that's all I got
and it seems like they're keeping their
hands out of the development process
that's why like I'm okay with them
sticking true to the script and not
deviating too much because every time we
give these people okay switch things a
little bit but not too much they're like
oh they say switch things a lot let's do
it
yeah buddy
I'm just glad motive is getting to
finally if I can finish the game
um and that obviously and they're
working out daddy so I got the Oh Daddy
is somebody
they got two they got two of them
okay salute salute you already know what
a way Dragon what up bro I see you in
there yeah salute salute you know what
I'm saying okay I'm sorry I interrupted
you yeah I just I'm just glad they're
getting to make you know there's been a
bunch of false starts with games aren't
they making the Iron Man game that's
them right right I believe so yeah it
just seems like EA's is fine finally
realizing once again that hey single
player games matter let's let's do that
man they got the Phil dominance somebody
got the unity joint no they going crazy
pull up pull up on me
yep that's it so cool cool let's see
green that green Unity looks nice though
I like the way that goes yeah the green
leaves like fire yeah go down so look we
got that let us get the Super Chat saw
yeah well I got a couple we have a
couple
oh that was vulgar's Creek that brought
those no doubts got to put his daily
salute Rose Saloon
saneros five dollar Super Chat it high
five didn't drop people wouldn't be
talking yeah they would I think they
would probably be talking about the
numbers still yeah yeah I mean at the
end of the day like we want to talk
about games give us reason to talk about
games like we want this how are you
gonna be like yo if that game wasn't
good yeah but what oh could you imagine
if it was the score if it was for
smoking could you imagine yeah with the
head boss Morales
who gets mad that people excited we
gotta Gamers we gotta stop that's goofy
energy we gotta stop y'all you cannot
get mad when people are excited about
something that's a reflection on you you
guys
that you look mad someone is enjoyable
you guys
you know
so smiling you're doing too much
where we do that at this is weird I'm
sorry I normally don't come at people
it's just goofy continue then we have uh
Tyson Lewis member for one year 20 live
Super Chat thank you brother appreciate
that
then we got Robert kellett two dollars
in the chat who needs Platinum when you
have Tango yeah
well apparently all Studios shouldn't be
pigeon
do anything
we have Donald Taco remember for one
year five dollar Super Chat there's a
lot of games that have unique art styles
and gameplay but none that are as
polished and well executed as HiFi Rush
this is a genuine 10 out of 10. wow okay
then we have Donut Taco again five
dollar Super Chat when's the last time
you played a game that didn't have a day
one patch and didn't have a patch in the
first week because it didn't need one
no way that's crazy that's kind of weird
that's like it's different
we have Lord roughness five positive for
chat it's only trying to stop the
Activision purchase they need to be
worried about the Bethesda purchase
Hi-Fi Rush redfall Starfield are the
real deal that's what it is and and
what's crazy is like this is an Elder
Scrolls six this isn't even within three
or whatever else Tango studio is working
on this is I ID or or whatever they like
to call themselves this isn't
wolfenstein's team uh machine games like
like they haven't even their best
Studios haven't released nothing yet
yeah
impressive yeah and we have romelo 20
Super Chat usually a lurker or Watcher
or Watcher of the show during the week
but wanted to show my appreciation what
you guys do cheers thank you brother
blessings much love thank you
now we have Danny passion official
s
stop the frogs coming up the head it's
the real one official official
two dollar Super Chat lies of P or
stalker 2 for the next Shadow drop
question mark
um I'd like them to Shadow drop more
stuff that we don't know about as
opposed to don't we know the date
philosophy uh it's in line to be
supposed to be in this first half too
which is crazy and so to me you've
already started a marketing cycle in a
sense with these games nah give me
something that I don't know about it
yeah the Tommy card same thing doing
something that you don't know about this
dope yeah yeah
Last of Us three Xbox
you know said to hell with what you was
trying to do to me I ain't gonna ever be
putting the box is The Rock
he got that HBO money different
I'm taking my talents across the street
I'm different
but Neil the IP belongs to slowly I
don't care I don't care
he's going across the street
find it funny that Hi-Fi Rush completely
Elden ringed Craig spoken wow
let's say less all hail Tango Game Works
messiness he'd be doing too much I love
Flames Flames don't do it way too much
out here continue then we have Donald
Taco member for one year five dollar
Super Chat I just want to say some of
these Xbox dudes of frauds because if
this was a Nintendo game they'd be
talking about how they don't play kids
games stop being bad
I'm so upset you having fun
I can't stand these dudes happy
because
oh my God
that we got stash Gordon remember for
eight months
when you were in my house
[Laughter]
you got that I just want Xbox to make a
deal with wise net oh he's not and deep
silver to continue uh the shenmue series
by publishing right on Game Pass seems
like a perfect fit
going there
you can save yourself from these hands
[Laughter]
you got anything else
we got 108 dragons TV five dollars for
chat they out here mad at peeps enjoying
games like my man LeBron was pissed over
that missed call we play games to enjoy
if you mad change your hobby back
let's run away let's say facts
so make sure you're sounding good
sounding great hello hello there we go
brother oh man
absolute solution let's get to it man
Hogwarts Legacy looks like a lot of
anticipation people really excited about
it you know mostly but there is some
controversy we have to address it and um
obviously the developers of hardwood
Legacy have stated that JK Rowling is
not directly involved with the creation
of the game they even addressed it in
the fact section of the website but this
is because they suggested they know this
will be a topic a concern for fans and
the statement they put out was JK
Rowling is not involved in the creation
game but as create as the creator of The
Wizarding World one of the world's
greatest storytellers her extraordinary
body of writing is the founding of all
projects in The Wizarding World they
explain but the big point of contention
here appears to be her views in regards
to the trans community and ultimately
her benefit fitting looks like from The
Profit so there's a lot of contentions
of whether or not you know this game
should be supported and uh again just
for clarity normally the Lords we kind
of stay out of politics of religious
sexuality however this does pertain to
gaming right this does pertain to an
intense it highly anticipated release
and I want to shout out Lord Ty for
approaching me because he said hey man
you know I want to kind of come on and
show I'm not seeing the other side of
the argument and a lot of the discussion
so shout out to Lord Ty you know for
coming in when you know we gotta gotta
provide balance in the realm to hear
every side of the argument so a lot of
times before we ask about the
controversy part I wanted to ask you a
question in reference to any connection
to Harry Potter or any love of the
franchise okay okay
um so I was probably going to open that
up anyways I couldn't find my wand I had
double doors one okay okay slash uh one
of the the you know God level artifacts
um that Harry collects along the journey
I couldn't find that but I'm a Ravenclaw
okay um first some foremost growing up I
read all the books and at first you know
being a hairy hairy boy
um I was like oh like I want to be
Gryffindor I took the test like several
times
um and I got Ravenclaw and a little bit
of Slytherin that's my number two I was
like oh I'm Gonna Keep it I don't want
to do one way or the other okay but
um yeah so uh
I'm a big fan of the world I've been to
the uh Wizarding World of Harry Potter
at Universal
um Orlando
and uh I think that
um the world is beautiful it it has its
problems as well as
um
that's a Fantastical place that I might
touch on when I talked about
um purely problems I have with the game
itself as well
um but yeah I'm also a big fan of Harry
Potter
um one of my friends roommates
um she is one of the equity singers or
the Harry Potter singers inside the park
itself
um so regardless of what's discussed
today slash
um all the problems are surrounding this
game I still think it's a beautiful game
I still think Harry Potter is a
franchise is one of those greats um when
you talk about like uh or the ring Star
Wars Star Trek um it's not a surprise of
why Harry Potter has stuck with people
for so long and why Harry Potter's such
a contentious topic yes when you talk to
people about it no thank you thank you
for that and then obviously let's get
right into the to the nitty-gritty you
know the controversy you know about
obviously JK Rowling's comments you know
it seems like the Gaming Community there
is a split you know where some people
will say look I can't get behind this
you know whether
he seems to be very against the trans
Community a lot of people are saying you
know you know they're torn because they
love the universe the fact that right
right came out with a comment that said
that you know she's not directly
involved and then obviously the profit
aspect where people say hey if you
support well it's get it's giving to her
who is who seems to have a very Pro
anti-trans stand so where do you sit
with all of that
um first and foremost I will say
something that I think both sides should
be able to agree on that this is going
to be a personal choice first and
foremost I don't condone anyone
attacking people in DMS in the comments
section death threats things like that
shouting this or that
um because you know life is hard and
everyone has their own reasons or their
own um acts that they bring along into
it now that being said I'm probably
gonna say things that you might not want
to hear but a lot of people need to hear
because there's just a lot of uh
discrepancy slash knowledge that's not
being shared first JK Rowling herself
you know everyone knows who she is at
this point but what they don't know is
they hear this controversy and they
think that
it's anti-trans comments that were
either misconstrued or something she
said a while ago
no JK Rowling is probably one of the
most
dominant anti-tran slash transphobic
figures right now just this past
holidays she had this big campaign I'm
campaigning against the people of
Scotland fighting for Trans rights and
human rights and their legislation she
spouts a lot of anti-trans rhetoric
um popular stuff like you know trans
people are gonna
come into your bathroom or men are using
this to rape women in restrooms and um
is on the platform of that she deems as
feminist but exclusive excluding
trans women as not being real women she
thinks that it's a tact from
um misogynist right who Prey Upon
women's values
um and that's you know that's a whole
lot of things we can dive into why
that's not the case and why that's just
dividing the fan base slash people in
general when Harry Potter as a franchise
supposed to be one that's very inclusive
or you yourself Jake has said that this
is an inclusive environment
but yeah no she's
um going on Twitter and taking Jabs at
trans individuals are coming out
speaking against her
um more than once she is um greatly
showed off her wealth and how her Harry
Potter royalty checks are going into her
pocket right and she's using that to
further her anti-trans slogans and
platform
um so when we come to situations of of
where she wasn't directly involved in
making this game but she's still making
royalty checks from it
um
like I have no doubt she probably could
care less about video games slash what
this game does but I'm willing to bed
that she would use the success to have
some jab online
um against the trans Community once
again
she makes posts like happy Turf Miss
people don't know Turf stands for Trans
excluding radical feminists and things
of that nature so JK is just an active
problem that I think people don't
realize and that's why
in this situation
in my opinion you can't separate the art
from the artist when you have someone
who's still being funded from this and
who is making such a big deal about
um marginalizing different communities
got you so as just final question for me
I mean for you because I'm trying to be
fair to you and make sure I represent
your point accurately
um your final stance obviously you said
your love for the the universe you said
your love for Harry Potter but as a
result of this you know you're not
separating and your stance is you I'm
not supporting this because of these the
way she's revealing herself on her
accounts and I'm glad you're Educators
like this is stuff I'm learning as I'm
going on so my question is I guess the
other question I have for you is a
reference to the other side who people
say hey man like I just want to play a
game or whatever whatever like like how
do you feel for to those people who may
still say hey I'm going to pick up this
game
um
on the one uh I'll start by saying that
like I understand it's
it's really
um tough to navigate these Waters when
it comes to different things because we
talked about
when it comes to the stuff in the Gaming
Community a lot of times you know
um it's really going to be a test of
character what's the breaking point when
it comes after something that you
yourself love
um so I understand that you know you
might be a die-hard Harry Potter fan and
this might be like the best Harry Potter
experience today that people are getting
and that you don't want to have to worry
about the baggage or the trappings that
comes to playing that game
um I will say that I don't think it's
fair to say people who are going to
purchase play this game are inherently
just transphobic out the gate I think
that's I think that's a misdirect that
doesn't really come to the heart of the
issue of what we're trying to talk about
um
I think that you know you should maybe
take an extra step and trying to figure
out ways that you can't directly send
that money to JK where it's like you
know buying used or something that's
that in the third or at least educating
yourself on the matter and
um because I think this should be a
teachable moment first and foremost
um
but
I feel like
it's it's a awkward line when you have
people that say Hey like I have no
problem with trans people like that's JK
spinney has nothing to do with me
um I just want to play a Harry Potter
game but like I'm an ally to the lgbtq
community
but when you have moments like this when
you really are pressed and we are asking
you
to make a conscious choice you know to
at least think about it
and
we get this that and pushback then you
know it's hard for someone to believe
like
like are you actually an ally when we're
asking you to at least you know
um pick a step up or people who are
asking for help because there's a whole
lot of other problems are going on in
the real world when it comes to this
community and other marginalized
communities just things like every day
something's happening right and so when
when this type of rhetoric is leading
over into the gaming sphere because game
is supposed to be for everybody we have
one group who feels like one of the
people that's attacking them is now
encroaching on their space and they're
asking for help and you're getting
pushback of like you know I feel you I
got nothing to do with me though I'm
gonna play this game it's heartbreaking
look that that's an honest assessment
and first of all salute to you Todd for
coming on being courageous to to tackle
the the subject we know it's contentious
we know
you know a lot of people on different
sides of it and obviously the the
pushback on Twitter as well as the you
know I would say I don't know if it's
fair to say like the opposite pushback
for people like hey I would have support
this game before you know I'm not even
gonna whatever so look let's get right
to it I'm sorry if that was your final
point I want to make sure you get
everything that you wanted to say off
before I move on to everyone else to get
their their anything else oh you are you
good
um I think that's pretty much it I mean
if we want to look at the game and this
have to reserve final judgment to see
how the game actually plays out right
um it's been noted before that there's
some uh anti-medic discrepancy slash
comparisons that have been made with
Harry Potter when it comes to their
portrayal of goblins right
um specifically you have like how the
goblin looks
um classic Nazi caricature and things of
that nature and in this game you seem to
be
Welling a goblin Rebellion again I don't
know if that's on the developers or they
did work with JK's team so I don't know
if they're like hey you gotta have this
in this timeline but quality and
government Rebellion for goblins who
were trying to essentially get equal
rights slash not be enslaved like the
house elves
um also doesn't I'm sorry feel right by
me like how those people don't know we
basically had a had a light
pro slavery thing with house elves and
Harry Potter
um
Dolby don't be the household yeah okay I
know this is
education
wow that's still a thing for people like
just worried about the game snowball
it's right there in the game too okay
that's also my issue
about respect one thing about the realm
you know even when we disagree or we
have different viewpoints we gotta hit
all sides so let's get to it I don't
know whoever wants to jump in addict or
um solve solve I know you you add some
strong comments before I don't know if
you want to go next or
absolutely oh my whole hand up oh no no
go ahead again
it looks like the the woman who played
uh tez and Last of Us just passed away
oh no are you serious wait in the moon
it's trending on Twitter right now I
believe it's the voice actress the voice
actress passed away yes yeah wow
condolences that's crazy that's crazy
I'm sorry wow
I don't even know where to go with that
um
well okay so I'm totally ignorant and
oblivious to all the stuff that was
going on but my thing is
um why don't everybody just batting
together and counselor
I mean everybody can cancel Kanye for
saying whatever he says right or anybody
can uh cancel uh Kyrie for having his
beliefs right so she has a belief that
it's toxic
cancel
now separating the art
um from the individual
this is this is it herein lies the rough
the studio the developer
the publisher
I'm pretty sure the publisher knew her
comments and her stance
yeah they came up with it but they like
the licensee though
we got to get that license
because that license is like a gold
ticket right it's it's pretty much you
know with this license you're gonna put
whatever you're gonna put out with this
license is gonna sell hot cakes now
you're becoming money over morals right
because
if this license wasn't valuable
would it still be uh a thing you
wouldn't you wouldn't deal with it right
if if it wasn't if it was more headache
then the money it makes you wouldn't
deal with it
so they go get the license so the studio
is like okay we're gonna make the best
game that we can make and the studio
makes the best game that they can make
but she's not involved with the studio
at all
and she's not involved with writing for
the studio anything they're just using
her her books and her her law and the
Publishers using the license
and now the developers there so we're
going into the Developers
that are they aren't transphobic I think
the uh the actual act main actress was
Radcliffe and a couple of them he came
out and spoke that they do not agree
yeah they don't agree with none of this
stuff because
they just want to make a great Dope Game
and they got a license to work on
something that they love right could you
imagine you you love this this this
product you love this story you love
everything about it to find out that the
individual is talking against something
that represents you as an individual
that's heartbreaking right so you have
these developers that's making this game
and this is how they make their money
this is them you have the publisher that
you know if I don't get a good licensee
a license and I make a good game from a
known product my company can fold
money over morals again we back to money
over morals now here as consumers
this is now me with my ignorance I
didn't know anything it is I just went
and picked it up the game hey I'm out
but
that's it not knowing right so you can't
say that those people that picked it up
not knowing is transphobic all right now
it comes to knowing
now wow what is your decision
I'm sorry to break the news
a lot of these individuals that say in
your face oh you know what I stand like
this but if it's something that they
have in their heart they're gonna
they're gonna find the separation
between church and state all right
they're gonna find the fine line to say
that those developers had nothing to do
with this and and I don't I don't
support what she's saying but I do
support the developers so they're going
to find a way to get to whatever they
feel is is their advice it's always
where they morality is and what really
matters to them what I'm saying is
if individuals do not like her rhetoric
do not like anything that she says
counselor
blacca
banha
don't buy her products but at the same
time
don't look over at the other individual
that does patreon to wears because they
don't have this same
I'm not going to say moral compass
because it's again
it it's all subject to the individual
right
but if you see certain something that's
going to hurt somebody
a friend of yours have that conversation
break down the conversation to the
individual that you know
is dealing with that thing that they're
talking about
terribly about them you understand you
gotta you gotta put yourself in both
shoes but I can see
where the art really had nothing to do
with the rhetoric okay
foreign
I think for me
the problem is that
the vast majority of the discourse that
happens around subjects like this
doesn't happen like it's happening here
right I agree yeah
so you sit down and you you see all this
stuff online and it's mudslinging
from extreme points of views
and what bothers me about that is that
as human beings
we survived because we're the most
nuanced species on the planet
we have the ability to
function in the gray areas
because everything is nuanced we have
the ability to separate you know the ID
from the ego and we have all of those
things where we don't just operate on
Instinct because if we all operated on
Instinct just pure Instinct black and
white
we'd we'd be dead long ago
so I have an issue sometimes with
radical views on either side of an
argument because ultimately there's
always going to be a situation that
arises
that every individual that stands on
either side of those arguments on the
far sides of those arguments
is going to be put into a position where
they're going to be hypocritical about
something because as human beings we
survive in the gray areas we live in the
gray areas constantly so when I look at
the negative discourse around this and
it's not a moving the conversation
forward right you aren't having a
conversation with with JK Rowling and
asking her hey why do you feel this way
I feel this way because the conversation
isn't happening it's just her saying
what she feels that she has to say and
there's something to be said about
somebody who has gained a certain amount
of money and privilege and status in the
world in the feeling that they have to
say something right
no we're gonna say no I'm sorry I I
shouldn't interrupt you I was just going
to say I did see again I'm still
learning about this situation so if I'm
wrong Tyler correct me
um I did see some posts she made and I
guess people were like hey I can't
respond to that like it's it's like a a
quote-unquote anti-trans phobic program
I felt they wanted to respond or she put
out something Nick the turf thing or
whatever and then some other back and
forth with Stephen King
and then Stephen King was like yo she
blocked me yes whatever yeah so whatever
so I just wanted to say because I know
what you mean in reference to having the
discourse but it seems both sides are
extreme at least you know those are kind
of per side and then some accounts from
the other side saying that you know so
that's the thing right thoughts are
being explained or whatever right it's
an unwillingness to have the hard
conversation and the very easy thing to
do for people is to have take one side
or the other yeah and not understand
that we all in had we all inhabit the
gray that is who we are
um and to act like you're never going to
be put in a position where something you
feel the thing is gonna you're gonna be
hypocritical about something it's gonna
happen so my feeling is just like
I don't I can't abide any of the
sentiments that come out of either side
of those extreme versions of the
argument so I'm going to take it just
from a societal and moral thing for me
this woman
regardless of what she said right
I don't see the conversations happening
to try to every for everyone to sit down
and Tackle this as as a species as human
beings I don't see those conversations
happening way away right we've said a
lot in the past that you know when it
comes to cancer culture it's more about
silencing people's opinions precisely
precisely exactly and that
anytime somebody has tried to impose
their views on on other people or
another it's never going well yeah
because people go shut down like you
don't tell me what it is it's never
going well automatically shut down that
is true so so my thing is this I just
take it from the point of view this is a
woman that has children
this is a woman that has family
put yourself in her shoes or anybody
else's shoes that has been sort of
yeah zeroed it on in this way and again
she took the initiative to say what she
needed to say knowing full well that
would be backlash so it's not like she
stumbled upon it right she's saying
these things because she feels she needs
to say them and that is on her she will
have to deal with the consequences of
that and for the most part she's
accepted the consequences too she has
but I I put myself in that position if
somebody
if I said something that was taken a
certain way or I meant it or whatever
the case may be and the conversation
around me turned to F this person he's
the worst right because what happens is
that the original thing that is said
it becomes a vicious game of telephone
and at the end of that game of telephone
is a complete Distortion of what was
originally said A and B it gives the
people who like to engage in this type
of discourse the ability to blanket
attack you in any number of different
ways and categorize you into any number
of different categories that can be
totally false and irrelevant to what was
originally said and I don't think that
benefits anyone so for me when I look at
the situation look at it purely as a
human being and secondly going on the
threat of human beings
the dev team doesn't have anything to do
with this like you time like me they all
love Harry Potter the world
and
I understand that's this is another
thing I want to be clear I respect
anybody's stance that they're not going
to support this game for the reason for
whatever the reasons they are whatever
side of the argument it is what I can't
abide is and you said this at the
beginning Ty is the discourse that has
people slinging mud at one another
saying you're this if you fi if you
support this you're not this if you
don't support this because at the end of
the day
we're always going to be put in a
situation when we take a stance like
that that makes us hypocrites
and ultimately for me
until we have real discussions around
this and get people to sort of open up
and start understanding the other side
nobody wants to understand the other
side of the argument
I never understood that if you're if you
have questions about things or you don't
understand things or in JK Rowling's
case right I see her this is me looking
at her she's a she's nearly a 60 year
old woman she grew you know her
generation is different it's hard when
you've grown up thinking and seeing a
certain thing all the time to all of a
sudden being told that is wrong not not
hey the there are things that that are
different that you should see
differently stubborn too those those
stubbornness there right there's a
stubbornness there and again all of that
has been pushed to the side
that Nuance in understanding the
situation and maybe reaching some common
ground where discussions can be had is
gone
and what you have is fjk Rowling she
sucks when I see when I hear the
discourse on kind of funny
being they talk they're talking about
the game now they're talking about the
game man but every chance they talk
about the game they say hey preface it
with fjk Rowling she's the worst
but no one says no one comes on here
like you did Ty and start detailing the
things that you've seen that make her
the quote-unquote worst
and for me that type of mudslinging
you're not moving the conversation
anywhere you're just saying I've I've
I've decided to gang up and label and
Bully right and my problem with the
bullying thing is this
when you look at people of color when
you look of nerdy People Like Us Gamers
right
we we've lived all our life kind of
bullied right and what I see a lot in
this cancel culture stuff is that
when you talk about you want Equity
right Equity is balanced Equity is going
back to the middle right
when people talk about Equity they don't
mean equity
they want the pendulum to swing in their
Direction
and they want to be have the right to
abuse their abusers in the way that they
were abused that's what they really mean
when they say that when they engage in
that type of discourse and are unwilling
to meet in the middle and talk to have
the discussion yeah exactly so for me
that is where when I look at this when I
look at this game when I look at the
hard work that's being put into it when
I look at the love that's it's being put
into it from people who love this world
to me for me
it is a stronger I have a stronger pull
to make sure that these devs that have
that have been working hard on this game
that we've seen in the past couple of
years particular the way studios are
just getting destroyed and ripped up and
and game being a Dev is difficult enough
so when the discourse around your game
is shut this game down again an
incorrect discourse in my view because
of the extremity of it
when you the discourses shut this game
down it has to fail at all costs because
JK Rowling is the extreme he is the
worst I I have a big problem with that
because again
there's hypocrisy within that
and we have to all understand that the
only way we move forward is to have the
hard discussion about it
and if it comes out at the end of it
that hey she's unbudging and she really
is she is a hundred percent sort of uh
on attack completely against trans
people and trans rights understandably I
completely understand a person's stance
saying that yeah I can't mess with any
of this at all but for me
we're all human we all deserve the
opportunity
this is why it's fair right we talk
about again the equity and being fair
I don't like hearing people spewing
racist stuff and things like that but
again when you think about where the
balance is if we want equity and balance
you can't have one without the other and
that's a very difficult thing to to
accept the fact that hey if I want to
enjoy and love the things that I love of
being free
the opposite end of the equation has to
be satisfied as well as much as we
dislike that see what you're going I'll
see where you're going I'll jump in
unless that's it I'm sorry
um
so
man all right let me all right when it
comes to something like this
like okay what we have options we can
either not buy your game or buy your
game well let's let's tear about what
both options do you don't buy your game
she's still a billionaire you buy your
game she's a more wealthy billionaire
and to me like at that point not buying
her game
what's that realistically going to do to
her like she's so she you know people
might not touch the Harry Potter brand
and maybe she won't make as much money
in the future but it's just like this
woman's already making plenty of money
she doesn't even make the game she don't
need to be licensed games she don't even
need the money from the game
I get it
the mindset is she can use that money to
to
campaign more with this but she already
has a huge following it doesn't take any
money
to tweet and she has a huge mass of
following on Twitter so I don't think
that's gonna really do anything uh
either uh when you look at it from the
standpoint on
morale
if everyone stood on this hill
that everyone's got to stand on the hill
of everything there's a lot of stuff
that goes on with other companies
that a lot of people don't really put
shine on there's really nasty stuff
happening outside the United States
where if you stood on that Hill you
wouldn't buy anything
wouldn't Buy iPods wouldn't buy clothes
and it's that that's where it's like
when you back something
it's hard to know when to stop it's hard
who it hurts it's hard to it doesn't
hurt and
then we got to take her from the morale
of
a woman in general
I don't feel like I
it's affecting me enough
to where I can tell a woman who she
decides as another woman to me I can't
do that you know I'm not being affected
by it I can't tell Roland how she thinks
is a woman who are not a woman on
another individual and she's not the
only person I've seen this you know I I
feel uncomfortable it's it's like with
abortion rights and stuff like that it
doesn't evolve my body so it's kind of
hard for me to tell her you have no
opinion to this because it doesn't
affect me but it affects her you know
we've seen stuff like
the the sports
Fiasco where you've seen the what Saul
brought up earlier as well when it comes
to uh you know the the bathrooms and
stuff and you know regardless
how serious you take these things or how
not serious you take these things
a lot of that stuff besides you know the
chill uh the bathroom uh scenarios it
doesn't affect men and that's why when
it comes to stuff like this it's just
like
I can't tell women what to feel because
and you got to look at from the
standpoint too it's like soft said you
know you got this older generation
they've they're used to the way life has
been for decades generations and it's
kind
I can understand
older generation in general have a hard
time interpreting such some basic stuff
like technology
imagine having your entire world put
upside down like it's not the way you
have been doing stuff your entire life
and that's why when it comes to these
kind of situations I don't talk about
them because it's like you know I can
give my opinion on this I can give my
opinion on that but at the end of the
day
do I have the right to speak on it and
I don't think I do I just don't that's
fair
um
so I expect I just take that you know if
you don't know if it doesn't affect
you're not a part of the community it's
hard for you to really have
um a vocal stance on something
um
but the the key points that I want to
hit again is won the money uh I kind of
iterate before but I'll stay clearly now
obviously JK's still gonna be making
bags either way her while it's not gonna
be hurt
um no matter how many people don't buy
her game that's not the point and that's
not the issue I was trying to bring to
the table is that this should be a
teachable moment more than anything in
that um to bring awareness to the
subject and really you know start taking
a stance that's a line with the Trans
Community when it comes to bigger things
at stake outside the gaming spear
um that's what's more important whether
or not you're hurting a billionaire is
whether or not you're making an active
change in the community and active
change in the world and I think it
starts with a mindset and having people
actually care about something other than
something that's directly affecting
their day-to-day I think it's key
um
and that leads into you know how far do
you go with something you know you'll
have to start protesting everything and
I think the point is is that at the end
of the day like stops kind of is kind of
saying is that we should care about
being just good human beings that seems
to be a lot to ask for some reason yeah
just be a good human being
um and so it's ultimately about taking a
stand for something and you know again
it's going to come up to what does it
take for you
um for for you to your background your
knowledge on what you decide is enough
is enough
um you know if it's really to the point
to where you don't want to have to
combat everything so you might as well
just combat nothing I mean that's really
sad in my opinion that you know you
don't want to stand for anything because
you don't have to worry about what that
entails or the traffic I feel that I
want to jump in and again just for you
know me Cox always definitely Advocate
on everything but um I I think where
where the issue lies and I think we're
out of I don't add it correctly if I'm
wrong because we think I'm misspeaking
um these moral complex complex decisions
sometimes can be tough because
I think what I think I was trying to say
was that like if you I understand it
completely about taking the stand I I
completely get that and I feel it's a
personal choice if someone is part of an
infected group if someone wants to
support the affected group
I'm concerns like you you can support
that you can take a stand and involve
your wallet at the same time I think
we're in an era right now where we
cannot completely be absolved from more
from this moral High Ground thing and
what I mean is that there is that's what
I was saying yeah that's what they're
going to say yeah if you're going to
stand on a more High Ground I expect
that energy towards everything yeah and
it's impossible to do it's getting what
I'm noticing again I'm making excuses
for taking a stand what I'm noticing in
life it is getting harder and harder to
take that I would consider the Purity
standpoint because everything seems to
have some type of dark underbelly may be
secretly attached and we have to then
once we have that information now what
do we do right so again if someone wants
to take that stance completely fine in
the fact that yo this is hurting a group
this is hurting the community I'm not
supporting that respect I can respect it
on the other hand I can respect someone
saying yo
I love this game this game means so much
to me I love this universe I grew up
with this universe and for the record
I'm not I don't I'm not a Harry Potter
guy I don't the it feel childish to me I
I I felt it was not for my demographic
personally right but when I saw the
preview of the game because I had
watched the movies I was like damn that
looked like they really captured the
essence of they Wizarding out here like
this is it I'm like yo that looked kind
of cool then I started to see the
discourse and I started to see people go
yo
you know I'm supporting this even after
the fact because I love this I grew up
on these books this is everything to me
and I just want to I want to give a
quick story because I can you may be
able to relate to this
this is where again
and I know you talk touch about it
briefly TY but as I've gotten older I
have learned to separate the person from
the art and the reason why I say that is
because
there are times in life an attic you
know that some people that you know me
you are mutual friends with that because
of their political views sexual views
whatever you know I am on the opposite
side of that right and I vehemently
disagree right but what I've learned I
get older is at least like solve is
saying to be able to have the
conversation and not vilify them because
I don't feel and there's some things I'm
not budgeting on top like there's gonna
be some things I'm like nope nope I
don't care I'm I feel this way you feel
that way you over there I'm over there
but the thing I'm learning to do is to
have the conversation to understand why
they feel so strongly so maybe that
helps me push the conversation forward
it helps me connect that and bridge the
gap the story I'm gonna tell real quick
if y'all allow me is um okay
you know how much your boy was The
Ultimate Warrior
all right like let me tell y'all
Ultimate Warrior was the world to me
little you know young Cog superstars of
wrestling I see this guy come through
face paint hits the music run it he was
a superhero to me I thought wrestling
was real
this man was everything to me and then
you know everybody on my block is Hulk
Hogan fast Hulk Hogan is the biggest
thing in wrestling and here comes this
wild dude so I'm like I cool then the
faithful moment WrestleMania six the
tassels the face paint I felt I was
giving him energy so I gave Warrior the
power to beat Hulk Hogan and be the
first Babyface versus Babyface champion
and I was like yes right
so I never forget right
right by my hero ultimate
later on life he gets out the game
start hearing about these speaking
engagements he would do he would go
different places and stuff like that you
know he was very conservative and you
know and he kind of made some comments
that troubled me you know he kind of
made some comments that were
anti-gay you know anti this and it
started to become a thing and I'll be
honest with you I was really conflicted
because I'm like damn this is my hair
like yo why is he wilding out like and
I was in a conundrum like can I support
him
you know what I'm saying after all of
this and as I've gotten older I've
learned to say
I represent I love the thing that he the
character that he Betrayed at that point
of my life and that was important to me
but I could separate but yo fam I'm not
with you on this part here now in my
case I got a personal
happy ending in the story so to speak
because one of his final matches because
I worry was very anti right
one of his final matches he faced the
wrestler called Orlando
Jordan I believe his name
openly out
openly and Warrior brought his kids and
his stick to the so obviously they're
like how is this even did he technically
shouldn't be doing this right and this
is without the muddied out the Fanfare
he's out of the W there's no money
really like that get involved this was
like I want my kids to see me in my last
match but I'm doing this against the
person who quote unquote views and
represents so to me it was a teachable
moment I felt how I internalized it was
growth now not everyone's gonna have
that story that I have but what I'm
trying to say is
what I've learned as I've gotten older
is I have to be able to separate the
personal views at least so I can have
the conversation and that's the only
thing where I lean with with some I
don't know Jay I could only go by what
I'm hearing with this jaycar roster I'm
just grilling the information now as it
goes right so that's where I can go and
I can't vilify someone and say yo fam I
just want to buy the game I love this
this means everything and I have people
I've spoken to people in the trans
community that have told me hey Cog I
love this game I want to support like I
want to play this game I'm disappointed
at what she's doing I am disappointed at
what she's doing but I love this this
universe the whole purpose of the
Universe from what I understand is about
inclusion yeah like that's what I heard
like I don't know this is why it's the
wildest thing to me yeah because when
you brought it to me I thought it was
something that was in the game right
right and then I said you know because I
don't I don't romanticize a lot of
things I'm not a fan of too many people
but it like the cogs saying like when
you meet your Heroes and they fall short
of your expectations
you're left in this space and then what
happens is if you start meeting your
Heroes and a lot of them start
disappointing you yeah then you realize
you can't really be friends but nobody
shows like I've learned I'm I personally
God cannot live his life where I just
cut everybody off because they have a
strong differing opinion than me you
know why you can't have those important
conversations and that's that's what I
was gonna say the wildest thing to me
was during a period of time where I
thought
uh Trump was hurting
a ton of things
my best friend
and
it got to a point where I said I gotta
have a conversation with you man like I
got to have a conversation with you
because you understand certain things
that he is being said hurts me
but you're opening openly championing
this situation
so please explain to me
and he broke it down so eloquently
where we just have to agree to disagree
but I I love the hell out of you yeah
like and me and it was tight as hell as
baby shoes but again
I just like you said Ty
conversations need to be had and people
have to say that conversation those
words are hurting me yes and if you're
standing by these words I please help me
understand why why
that part you know and it's and and like
like
Sovereign said
the ego
when you when you start to remove the
ego from the situation and say please
explain the words that you're using that
is hurting me why are you using such an
automatic label without the disrespect
without the help me understand why you
did yeah why are you there I completely
agree instead of attack I fought it in
the vilify it and that's on both sides
yes
it's for both it's not just for for one
because you can't just say oh you're
wrong you're wrong because then you're
taking a stance right but again it's
still the conversations that I know you
want to have Ty yeah that they need to
start having these conversations because
he helped me understand something I
didn't know right you know it's a
teachable moment
you don't want me to clarify what I mean
by like uh you know talking to other
women like she's not the only person
I've heard State these kind of opinions
no she's not and I'm not saying that I
agree with her opinions I'm saying that
as a non-woman I can't tell another
woman that her opinion about what
another woman is right or wrong that's
all I was saying and people trying to
like squirrel that into like 80
different things
as a man I can't tell you a woman you
know what women women think because I
don't think like a woman that's like
equivalent to me saying I'm white and I
can tell a person of color what
struggles they go through there like I
can't or what what offends
you offended by something that somebody
says I get it I don't want to beat this
too long but I'm not tired
yeah I'll wrap up this segment but just
saying because obviously
um like you're alluding to this is a
topic that we can spend all day talking
about
um conversations are important the only
thing I'll leave people with is that you
know
um being willing to have a conversation
is great but even more important you
have to be willing to
do your own research come to your own
conclusion by researching the facts you
know if you
don't listen to anything I say today do
your own actual research take your own
time to come up with a backed evidential
opinion and then I've done my job that's
all I want respect exactly all right
brother you already know salute salute a
king I do want to um get the the chat I
don't know if you want me to set it up
or the chat gbt
um comment because a little bit of hard
work but a little not so basically for
those who are unaware unless you got it
kick I'm sorry I don't wanna no no no go
go okay so then I can explain open AI
has you know chat GPT so apparent like
you know AI model to train model to
optimize language models and dialogue
you know we're starting to see the
prevalence of it
um a lot you know coming up you know it
has infiltrated The Newsroom I know we
had uh Gene Park on you know last last
time not that long couple weeks ago and
he talked about how you know the AI is
kind of like even doing articles sports
articles right where you do sports
scores and stuff like that you know I
know King you brought something to my
attention and reference to
um cheating you know saying in gaming
and stuff like that and then the other
thing which is kind of funny is related
to Hogwarts is that you know apparently
a 11 year old has made uh basically an
uh a chat a text-based video game based
on this technology you know so basically
it's like a template with scenarios
dialogue options and then it does this
predictive language based on the data
and stuff like that so King I know you
really wanted to talk about this so the
floor is yours Sir with the chat well
being that we have uh one of our Premier
writers from lordsgame.net on
um I believe uh this uh conversation is
very relevant because you know
separately in my life I you know look at
different things and look where we're
going as a species
um and it just kept coming back to AI
kept coming back to AI so I've been
doing a lot of different research on my
own about Ai and the advancements that
we're having as a species and then I
hear
um chat GPT and it just kept coming up
chat GPT just kept coming up so then the
YouTube algorithm gets a hold of this
thing and I guess it's because of
whatever I was researching
um it was networked into this thing so
the YouTube algorithm uh pops up and you
see people saying well you can make
fifteen thousand dollars you can make
eighty thousand dollars a month on Chad
GPT all you need is to do this then the
third so of course any entrepreneur in
his right mind is going to give these
things a look alright so I give these
things a look so then I realized that oh
my God this chat GPT thing is a AI
algorithm that uh is a text-based thing
that you can give it complex
instructions and it can do the work for
you right so instead of a tool to help
Humanity people are using as a tool to
ease their burden of work right now when
it comes to uh journalists they found
out that you can give the the chat GPT
uh basic outline of what you want your
body of work to be be it a thesis be it
a story uh be it a scores of a football
game or a basketball game whatever
sports game and it can do some in in
serious uh accuracy that you can't tell
that it was AI written and that directly
threatens journalists as we go forward
and and pretty much everybody that's
writing movie scripts and stuff like
that because they asked it to write a
movie script and it came out with one of
the most amazing movie scripts with the
casting and everything uh and the people
which is which is nuts
that this AI is making these Leaps and
Bounds my question to you is what level
of concern are you when it comes to this
uh technology and the rapid Pace that it
is moving because I believe it's a
threat to us I want to know what is your
opinion of it
um yeah I agree with that uh the use of
AI technology in the workforce has kind
of always been a concept but now we're
really seeing the um Fallout of that
being put into practice uh not too long
ago we had the explosion of air and
um back then a lot of people were either
oh hey this is a cute little thing look
what this can do for me or other a lot
of artists were like yo no this is like
problematic fam not only is this
infringing on my way of life my living
but it's also stealing work
um and that evidence like that has
carried over to now we have ai writers
um AI uh writers that are able to take
pieces and do like thousands upon
thousands of pieces through their
programming just like that over the
course of next few days
and we see
um people uh using these and
plagiarizing different works like Lords
of gaming has been plagiarized by
um the by these AI uh programs and it's
very problematic
um because
right now
um it's still developing so there's a
lot of instances we see where uh you
know kids trying to get out of homework
are using um chat programs to write
um papers for them and they're able to
be caught by the school system
um but as that becomes more problematic
you know what's to stop someone from and
you all talked about this before what's
someone from using it AI program to just
run a quick news piece trading state
facts or scores Esports things like that
versus hiring someone to do that same
piece of work and
um yeah and I'd say that
it's a lot of heart and soul that goes
into writing and AI
um is devoid of that that was the
argument against AR art and that's still
evident with AI writers is uh a lot of
people are on the globe especially at
Lords of gaming we put a lot of heart
and soul and character
into what we write and that's not
something you're going to get with
um an AI program and that's something
that I feel gets lost when you have
these corporations or people who's all
about the bottom line the bottom dollar
is that you lose that humanistic element
to it and that's the only way that we
progress as a unite race or as a
civilization is
um our humanity and things that we
create the things that we do it's why
you we still look to things during the
Italian Renaissance to The Works left by
the Greeks and the Romans of these
epitomies of human culture that have
stood the test of time
um greats like um Shakespeare and
um poetry all of this is a human element
and if you take that away trying to make
things easier slash make things more
cost efficient it brings great
instability to the industry we're just
now dealing with the Fallout of all
these layoffs that just happened and
that threat is becoming even larger when
you have things like chat GPT growing
more popular and being developed by the
day
a lot a lot to discuss here but that was
it or well said time uh solve addict you
want to jump in it's open Forum I have
bars in a few minutes I mean when it
comes to this
I I think that's why gene was so adamant
when we had him on that it's like we
need to restructure how the writing
scene's done in anything you know be
more about personality than just words
on a screen uh you know he was very uh
very strong worded about that I agree
you know I think for the most part a lot
of media form has went down since
influencers and streamers have went up
you know people trust following people
that they can have a daily access to for
the most part than someone that may or
may not have wrote in something you know
there's a lot of uh Shady so not to
mention you know there's been Time After
Time where stuff has happened in the
media where it just makes you know the
gaming media and uh you know in
particular just seem like they shouldn't
be covering games now is that everyone
know but when you keep adding these
little building blocks on top of each
other slowly people start to lose faith
that you know are these people playing
these games do they play these games
like they claim do they know what
they're talking about and you know you
get scenarios where people are
writing a review and someone else is is
doing the actual review you know I get
that but at the same time uh you know
then you have people that come out there
that review games that say beating a
game isn't necessary to review a game
and it's just like I don't see
influencers for the most part seeing
this I don't see streamers seeing this
it's always the media and then when you
consistently have this going on all the
time people are just gonna be like look
like if you guys don't even beat the
game why am I even go to the website I
mean I can't tell you the last time I
went to like an IGN or something you
know I go to lordsagaming.net though
there we go
yeah so it's just like you know things
need to change drastically and I don't
think anything's going to get better
until that drastic change happens you
know as far as uh chat GPT
it's technology it was bound to happen
sooner or later it's sad that's
happening sooner rather than later and I
hope it doesn't overtake anything uh but
you know there's been a lot of
industries that have been pretty much
machineized that AI are doing it so I
mean I hope we still got some fuel in
the tank but that's that's all
you try to fight the sky that side
of this
what's up the case ain't no one's seen
uh Terminator Genesis you're not
fighting that just submit
s
the list
Sundays
some of your thoughts
it's upon us you know what that means
though like so who's my who's miles
Dyson is it like John carbach yeah we
gotta go get John Carmack
it can't be reasoned with it can't be
bargained
GPT is here yeah man I I will tell you
this
what happens I built the body yeah
that's the thing right that's the thing
it's like
be careful what you wish
for be careful what you wish for it it's
just I I maybe it's the old man in me
but I do feel that there's just certain
things just
just don't go there don't go there like
this idea
of needing to automate and create some
that we have so little time to do what
we need to do that everything needs to
be automated and made into this hyper
efficient thing and it's just is lost on
me because like it's totally contrary to
the needs of human beings right I just
don't I don't understand that idea of
like well I don't have enough time to do
with this put some computer to do it and
we'll figure it out later
um that's how it starts though
it's all we it has an update enough to
work good what little finish it has an
update to where it's like now now let's
just prehistorically just make these we
don't even have to tell the robot the
robot's just gonna do it I want these
these articles out by Monday Wednesday
and Friday bought go do it but we used
to go to the to the Rite Aid
I know this is just this one thing here
so you can check out it's called
you see what
I've never understood how we create
technology to take ourselves out of the
equipment
you must though it's not us it's people
trying to make money and it's people
trying to save money
term right I mean you bought it as a
blanket sort of thing that we're doing
as in his Humanity are we stupid or what
like right
yeah
you don't have the workers in the back
trying to make something to stop their
jobs like you got the people of trying
to hire Engineers to find something to
replace their jobs stores in Japan you
have this little bracelet or you have
this little key card and you walk in
scans you as you walk in takes a
complete x-ray of you you have nothing
on you or whatever you come in as you
pick up stuff and put it in your cart
and you go through different checkpoints
in the store
the stuff automatically comes out of
your account comes out of the account
there's nobody in the store
just the people that are Patriot in the
store you get the stuff off the shelves
and you leave you don't go through a
scanner check out none of that it
already scans the stuff as you take them
and go
we are coming to a point where the
middle class and the lower class are
being erased in the upper class don't
get their hands dirty
what happens to us yeah that you know
what's crazy
you know I as someone who grew up in a
and not a household but around Rob like
radical Christianity
um you know the whole idea of like
how will the mark of the beast come
about in the modern world it's your
credit it's your credit card you're
going to have a microchip installed and
stuff like that and then when I got the
microchip in my credit card
it's just like when you start seeing
these things but it's a hundred percent
true right yeah it is it's the one
percent trying to figure out how to
maximize profits while minimizing
the need to support the human resources
at the bottom of at the bottom of the
total right took out the foundation
exactly and and it's what's sad about it
is is the scary about it is when you
look at these these AIS
initially you you don't see you don't
necessarily see the long-term uh
issues that that will arise from this
what you do see oh that's cute it can
kind of learn and answer and understand
the other
um but the problem with it is that a lot
of this work that was being done a lot
of this work that was being done by the
by big Tech and kind of kept Under Wraps
what happened was that you know you
always have people coming in and out of
companies that know what's going on they
have their hands and and what's going on
so now all of a sudden what happens is
chat gbt is a small is it it's
relatively small compared to the big
guys that have been working on it they
put their thing out there kind of almost
recklessly and say oh here here World
play with this and what happens is now
that chat gbt is out in the world it's
learning every single day right
so to the the extent to which it
plagiarizes and copies and quote unquote
learns from the things that are out
there is increasing exponentially every
single day and was worrisome about that
is is it being able to get to the point
where something that it poor that it
spits out
is completely you cannot identify it
separately from what something that a
human being has done that's the scary
part and this the fact that the work is
being done to get there the fact that
the work is that's being done is is in
order for it to get there is the
scariest part of it so to me King
bringing this up is is important because
at the end of the day when we start
talking about the way that
that uh the way that the way that uh
gaming media is kind of changing and
websites are sort of changing and the
idea of writing and or media in general
is changing and the idea that a lot of
this base level stuff that a human being
was doing is now being pushed off onto
AI because it's good enough
um
anytime you start anytime you start
being able to to rationalize eliminating
human jobs because a machine could do it
well enough
it is scary and in a in a world where
we're in recession now as it is
to create a situation where more and
more people find themselves
not being able to find work because not
everybody this this creates a vacuum at
sort of Base levels of work that people
can do where you know you talk about
like assembly lines and factory work and
stuff like that a lot of that stuff has
been automated as well so when you start
doing that in the sector that
yeah yeah when you start doing that in a
sector that requires a certain amount of
of expertise and education and all that
when that starts happening
we'll see we'll see what happens because
once this starts starting we're going
upwards yeah it started with us in
schools as far as the steel workers and
stuff like that remember you used to
have trades in school so you go to
metalworking and engineering and stuff
like that in classes we used to have
these classes those stuff was taken out
when uh the big uh well factories was
taking out and yeah with automation as
far as cars and stuff and building like
that in Detroit and stuff like that now
we're seeing it in the tech sector
but see it took a long period of time
for the factories to close down yeah
what we see right now
with this in
vention
of chat GPT and this is just one of them
what you're seeing now is the rapid
Decline and elimination of a space
whereas the factories took years
probably two generations we're going to
close this Factory at the end of uh such
and such a year you know so I think you
should get your stuff in order this is
not the case
this is uh yeah we don't need those
articles from you anymore
um we're gonna move you over to another
division uh Sandy I have your paperwork
at the front desk and you don't hear
from that again or they just you know
your key card don't work when you go
into Google you know um stuff like this
happens and this is happening as a
direct result of uh this AI this this AI
that they're using it's more Troublesome
I talked to Cog about it in the
background as far as how they're using
it to evaluate employees yes uh on your
time on your computer time on your time
that you check in you're being
documented checked and looked over all
day long and it's not humans that can do
it it's actually AI that does it a AI
can make faults it can make mistakes
when you come into your job site
you are assigned a number do you number
the the numerical number let's say it's
90. if you fall below a 70 you're in a
cut rate but who decides this AI is
deciding your your numbers and your
productive qualities that is necessary
for this company so if you're on a job
like a call center
the AI is monitoring how many calls you
take how many times you're on the phone
how many breaks you have and how
productive you are
we build these things to help us but at
the end of the day are these the same
things that replace us
I'm sorry again not to mention it's
going to make it almost impossible to
start out in writing because like the
things that this is going to take over
that's what the people starting on
writing do at first so yeah just
reporting news
yeah like the basic game you know even
longer you know we'll have people on you
know Tylenol like sometimes it's like
hey your first couple articles is we
ain't gonna have you review a game first
but we may say hey just put out a press
release on this or that if you're
thinking about in the sports sector like
what Gene was talking about was like hey
what put up the scores for the game you
know that kind of thing simple things
and now that you see that kind of
infiltrating that and taking that away
but um yeah it is interesting it's
something to pay attention to it's I'm
conflicted because I am very Pro-Tech
obviously you know what I'm saying but
and I always love to see the advancement
right but at the same time we we do have
to be cognizant of you know how Society
this this affects Society Long Term and
and if these algorithms advance I think
the issues right now for me is that the
algorithm to me is not smart enough
yet to then sometimes I see what Chad
gbt that these things are just incorrect
right right
yeah that it's trying to prove
nonsensical things but it just comes off
in a conversational flow way that make
it seems logical and then so but the
scary part is the the more gets better
and also to me a lot of people not
talking about is
you know the AI has to feed from
somewhere right so what
inherent biases of the person who are in
just you know in ingesting this
information are going to be now
transposed into this so let's just apply
it to gaming you know Cog is the
anti-souls guy so if I don't like Soul
Souls game when I'm programming you know
what I'm saying the the the the chat GPT
part you know what I'm saying to have a
skewed view the value it's also the
Creator right his inherent biases are
going to be put into that attic I don't
even jumping out finish my thought when
you finish it's like you're gonna have
one of these uh these scientists in here
use uh this this chat GPT and it's gonna
end up being the the core foundations
for for something like like a sign that
you've got someone making gay like a
movie
about it right when we talked about when
we talked about the way what does the
general discourse online look like a lot
of it is is toxic and negative
you just pull
Ed out he said
we can't have any chat DBT because every
God of Wars deals
this point should be great I don't know
if y'all remember this I think it was
like 20
there was a thing that Microsoft sort of
put out there called Tay Tay and it was
the same sort of thing like as a
Microsoft
no I didn't know what it was though the
thing was that people took it and they
put it out there right that you know
people got in there they didn't hack it
but the trolls started messing with it
because again it was and advanced enough
it hadn't had time to learn in an
environment that was not feeding it
negativity and somehow they were able to
manipulate what it was doing so there
was this like whole discourse it like it
was like the about 9 11 about Nazism and
stuff like that and it was just they had
to take it down in a day because it it
took one day which you would manipulate
what you were trying to get it to do
this is what you ingest and the last
point I will say is you always gotta
look
at the owner because if it takes off the
owners to sold control of this Tech and
that puts them in a position right and I
think that's right where a lot of
pushback comes from because when you see
regulatory bodies or whatever they want
to see okay who's going to control how
is this going to affect the competition
if they are the same
I ain't going there I swear to God I was
thinking about it
I tried not to get you know I don't want
no smoke right now with nobody
I'm leaving things alone
who the power is that V that are in
control of said Technologies you know
you have to watch because if they become
you know sole proprietary of the attack
and and there's no competitors in the
space that could get very it could
potentially get problems everyone has an
agenda
so it is it reminds me to um
topic
[Laughter]
oh um you talking about Gunner
yeah everyone talk and then we could get
out of here let's get him let him get
his bars off so
um over the week
we found out that bespoke came out ain't
do so well
Jim had twisted his ankle running in the
mailbox to see if the checks came in
so instead of going to the ER he went to
the EU
and he told the Microsoft tripped him
there we go here we go it's bad for us
did you not see the smoker came out and
it's for broken
Jim Ryan met EU Anti-Trust Chief I can't
pronounce this name Margaret vestiger on
Wednesday to discuss Microsoft 69
dollars
yeah for Call of Duty making Activision
for those familiar with the bad it's a
kid you feel this is this is a place in
the head alone
but you know what though I'm gonna give
it to Jim here because you see this is
and I quote
we've been clear we've offered Sony a
10-year deal to give them parity on
timing content
features quality liability and any other
aspect of the game the aspect of the
game does not mention this how they plan
to sell the game and where they plan to
sell the game and that is where parody
will never be achieved so Jim this is
this is Jim you know kind of telling the
truth really well according to it you
know
what I was told is like as I said yo but
you know they're offering they're
offering to put this on PlayStation Plus
and that I was told by someone that
would know a little one or two things
they're like yeah but but added like
that's not cheap
well the conversation continues as right
now it's it's it's uh Saudi Microsoft is
accusing Sony of lying to EU Regulators
about the Activision deal despite
instances instance that Call of Duty
remain on Playstation we have a very
vocal person for Microsoft Frank Shaw
who is the current lead of communication
he said I hear Sony is briefing people
in Brussels Brussels
to offer them parody for Call of Duty if
we acquire Activision nothing can be
farther from the truth we've been
cleared we've all we've been clear we've
offered Sony a 10-year deal to give them
parity on timing content features
quality playability other aspects of the
game we've also said we're happy to make
this enforceable through a contract
regulator agreement regulatory
agreements or other means Sony is the
console market leader and it would defy
business Logic for us to exclude
PlayStation Gamers from the Call of Duty
ecosystem and he said our goal is to
bring Call of Duty and other games as we
did with Minecraft to more people around
the world so they could play them where
and how they was so they are literally
accusing Sony of lying to Regulators
which is very interesting about that
damn liar all I want you to do is tell
the truth you can't handle the truth
is far more Sinister
it's a poison pill they want me to take
a poison pill the funny thing too it's
just like dude
I at this point I feel like Jim
knows that he he he's he's making lazy
at this point he might as well be making
tsunamis and he's trying to tip the ship
over at this point he's like I think I
think I got it man I think I think the
ship you know it's big it's huge but
water don't care
it's like the ship is like this about to
tip over and Jim Ryan's like to you like
listen whatever you got to do it you got
to protect this [__] yeah yeah I gotta
respect your time I want to get your ass
brother gotta go but um I want to get
your comments on these these things
before you head out so you know in the
latest in the uh Greatest
Hits
like you said Jim Ryan you know
I've never seen a better dance maybe
this man right here I'm gonna have to
start taking them to the club because he
just don't quit
um and like shout out to him because
he's doing exactly what he needs to do
and if you if we revised this like a
year ago when this first starting out
talking about this we didn't believe
there would be this much pushback
surrounding this deal and I like I want
this deal to go through it's I mean The
Shining Light to bring back from the
depths the glory of Activision Blizzard
fight
you know it's like the 300 with Jim Ryan
and his crew he's holding the line
making sure that it does not go through
we have the ftcc that the FTC that's
not wanting to use logic or play play
fair with anyone right now
um and it's it's just ridiculous but
no matter what on either side
um Phil gym they're gonna do what is
best what is correct for the
shareholders actually or the company and
um you know hats off to Phil for always
being the Pro Gamer like the gamer dad
The Good Old Uncle you invite to your
living room and shout out to Jim who's
the guy who comes to Christmas every
once in a while and uh Angie socks for
your presence
that's it you know um
on the one hand I applaud Jim for his
tenacity on the other hand I'm he got
out of jail he left YSL in there gotta
take a gonna take a page out of
Kingsburg I want everyone to either uh
shut up and lay down or get out of the
way because I'm tired
I appreciate anybody gonna get the bars
for me
attic solve y'all good yeah
why Excel is a game appreciate your
brother for coming through we're gonna
get before we do these super chats thank
you brother for for giving us ballots
you know lessons and cloudy on the other
side always next week
for the Lord's minute make sure to
follow if you're breaking down
um Star Wars the bad batch season two
currently each week
um after that we'll be go ahead I was
gonna say we gotta get you on r r one
week yeah yeah that's the perfect fit we
could talk um if you don't you can watch
that movie you people
King and I we cover a lot of uh shows on
the Lord's minute um we're gonna be
hitting up the Mandalorian season three
shortly after
um other than that I do a lot of Destiny
stuff and some other things over at
Lords of gaming.net and you can also
follow me on my social I couldn't get my
actual gamertag handle so I'm known as
Prince igneel on Twitter you can follow
me there
um for some meme sharing and other
nonsensical things and uh yeah shout out
I love you all the realm uh happy and
proud to be a part of this community
thank you have a good evening appreciate
it brother brother love you thank you
man love you tenacity you know and I
love what you bring to us you complete
us as a site this guy's a living with
you man the talent is tremendous keep
doing you and it's a pleasure to work
with you brother you know more things
together soon but every week you already
know the legend thank you so much no
doubt the time
because I always want to get the super
chat so you want it this is dead how
does this feel rip a stitch I mean I
just I just
she still is out here gonna face
what does that mean
they're gonna tell they're gonna snitch
they're gonna pay more
I have to turn off my uh yeah
we got Peter Mick 89 with the five euro
Super Chat hi Lords just wanted to say
love the content and look forward to
your podcast each week much love from
Dublin Ireland
Peter Peter Mick 89. oh listen I got my
Dublin gang on Deck yo we got the
Volaris like King said that's right link
is in the description use code law 15 we
out there we outside in Dublin now we'll
pick them up pull up with the floating
devices your valorian steel that
belonging still there we go post yeah
definitely don't put the pillows in the
water don't put them in the water no
don't do that you won't do it anyways
funny uh my girlfriend's daughter like
confiscated
oh no I can't use it the other night we
were heading to bed and because I
usually use it and and she's like I want
it like sitting there literally like
playing tug of war for three years see
that valari out here cause a problem
everybody in the family got a [__]
you gotta invest in chloroform
out here fighting with a three-year-old
yeah
the link is in the description you see
what these three-year-olds doing out
here is real you're watching Street
Fighters
go love 15 EU UK we outside and the US
let's go get them in March pre-ordered
now I am exclusive we got post up ten
dollars great games will always
supersede platform of choice true Gamers
find ways to access great games Hi-Fi is
a perfect example of this I've seen
PlayStation fans trash the game only to
apologize after playing it okay at least
they apologize after playing it you know
we're making progress making progress
man just don't just like people gotta
stop hating on other people enjoy it
that's all we got exactly exactly but
I'll hit on everything
that's just the attic way right
Dorian Gray two dollars a chat this is
why I'm sick of single player games
every one drama
not everything it's not drama man it is
you know serious situation serious
conversation that transcend into the
realm of gaming that's just what it is
it's it's like
it's like past great areas where it's
like tough conversations that need to be
have like yeah
yeah I guess we want it like everybody
else
sorry
then we got David Phillips one dollar
Super Chat shout out to David billers
for his first Super Chat that with the
crest in the Championships
then we got time 909 with the five pound
Super Chat though I prefer these
conversations not coming to gaming when
they do respect the IOP for the nuance
and varied opinions hashtag finish death
loop
I like how it was bad love and then it
ended in an attack on me man
[Applause]
[Music]
we got pragmatic ego member for for 30
38 months wow that's my guy Lord gold
shout out to IOP for being brave and
Resolute enough to start conversations
thank you brother appreciate it we need
conversations around situations
that's it yes and understand sometimes
you gotta have to understand even when
we agree to disagree you know what I'm
saying that's all that's understanding
then we got Jiggy clap two dollars
[Laughter]
are we getting a dead space some attic
people I guess the streets want you to
play dead space at it yeah probably so
oh my God
everybody be outside man you like that
death space you like that stream life
I got the high
uh Hi-Fi Rush which
I don't know when that's going on yeah
[Laughter]
I got the uh Fire Emblem I gotta finish
that okay okay which uh you know somehow
I start reviewing one game man I just
get thrown on a completely different one
I don't know how that happened and then
depending on what's going on I will
start dead space but you guys need to
relax and let me finish the stuff I got
in front of exactly I'm gonna finish
this food messed up all this and bottom
RDA
we got one away dragons TV two dollars a
chat the pony Master doesn't approve a
king's message
[Laughter]
remember for 38 months as well fantastic
Lord gold Jim out here scrambling to
avoid showing their papers because if
those papers come out Sony in trouble
yo they're not called ponies no more
they call Gunnies
[Music]
Jim went to Brussels to bend the knee
and open his throat yo what are we doing
what are we doing the gun needs it
outside crazy we got Jim guac guac three
thousand yeah
but you know I I get it you know that
that that's a lot of work man you know
what that is
a lot that is a lot of stuff on your on
your joints
before you get over there to EU take
some joint support
you you you want to do some Bend in the
knees like we got this right here that
will help your joints if that's easy use
code I love it you know the description
go check that wow
your joint Mobility there let's go
we care about your health man we care
about your joints wow Lord's 15.
I ain't lost somebody come at me that
code ain't work
yeah so he finished the Super Chat uh
yeah
three thousand Ryan suck it up to who
will listen wow okay they messy messy
then we got stash Gordon remember for
six months two dollars super chat with
the George Michael reference you gotta
watch it man creative got no rhythm
Joy
[Music]
yeah
that's crazy you're stupid all right
then we got tipped whale five dollars
got to go Lords the Dementors you sent
are here but awesome show and have a
good one yeah we sent the dementia slow
salute
then we have Jonas the dad dude
absolutely
that's his title
that's how you played out here King
Phil's finishing movement Mr Laden to
run the ABK imagine he brings Sean Laden
to running that's crazy
and yo Sean go up and then be like
everything that man says his lies
and then we have post up five dollar
Super Chat I don't think it's an act
with an accusation and and it could be
perceived as hearsay hence I hear uh I
think this was intentional from a legal
perspective yeah they listen they
playing chess we gotta wait for whole
plan
down in restaurants they ain't taking
them to Denny's yes when I saw a filter
but he's still confident I thought he
was going back down
it's hard don't pump no Kool-Aid man we
met him already you know what's up man
him and Todd they had that look about
them like
[Laughter]
any thoughts on the Benji report about
Hi-Fi Rush yeah we talked about it we
talked about basically how it um
dominated yeah it's ranked uh in Revenue
about thirty dollars it kind of at least
launch week outdated for spoken with a
shadow drop so yeah we talked about it
yeah more than half the price
GSD getting stuff done five dollar Super
Chat the quality of your life is
dictated by the quality of questions you
are willing to ask and answer yes so
we're enriched by our ability to talk to
one another yes absolutely that's what
we're talking about that's what we talk
about the conversation
then we have sir duck member for 30
months Lord bronze Jim out here like
wait there's more EU yeah
so do you like carrying head he got him
back
there we go 108 dragons TV two dollar
Super Chat wow Jim Ryan the throat goat
really awesome Brooklyn you need to stop
right now I know what you doing bro you
need to stop so we good yeah well you
know what there's one that I know I read
that for whatever reason it was you know
it was I can't where the hell is it okay
let me run back because there is
something that are you talking about the
one that said that we need to have a
universal uh budget no it was it was
that one it was talking about the
conversation about Hogwarts and it was
someone's take on it
um you know I think you got the one that
said about the universal budget though I
didn't get that one either I don't know
why I got jumped so far okay we all know
that's coming in gym
and then there was another one that was
a little you know took a harder stance
like it basically said like there's
there's no middle ground and that she's
transphobic and I don't want to leave
without reading that oh man I I don't
have it no more attic do you think you
could roll back because I don't know I
it seemed like I was right on point with
where I jumped from but for whatever
reason it is not to tell me like the
last one that you read who are we
thinking that that was missed hold up
I'm bringing it up now go check after
stash Gordon if there's anything in
there because I for whatever reason I
know mine said um I forgot who it was
from Adriana adronis it said that we
should have okay you want me to just
race
uh uh budget uh like um base uh
Universal basic budget
okay I'm just yeah
I'm just going to read a couple
um 108 Dragon uh
did you read uh fight out super trap
first of my brother before that we
missed before that too I'm looking there
I'm mad before that though post up did
you guys get post-ups
I mean read it because they might have
put multiple months we got a 10 super
trap from post up great gains uh we'll
always uh we got that all right so we
got yeah we're almost there keep going
uh fighters from mango mcstickens how is
having a belief in science and biology
which has proven fact
I'm sorry I'm sorry about that talk 60D
on both sides exists we gotta find out
from rubber knob most of the people
going to play in this game will be kids
though kids won't know what a trans
person is it's most parents will not
intervene uh five dollars per trap from
108 Dragon first of my first of my
brother uh Brothers great job on the
topic but three things as Gamers stay
away from are religion sex and politics
these are very touchy situations facts
yeah we got a two of us they're likely
to game again is why I'm sick of single
player games every one drama and we
added just a regular one dollar Super
Chat appreciate it man then we had a
five Super Chat from Tom 909 though I
preferred these conversations not coming
to gaming when they did that I'm reading
them all okay five dollars two dollars
per job from JK Cloud we getting a dead
space from attic we got a 10 super trap
from drug ba there aren't two sides to
transfer of you Jake had uh amped chance
to clarify herself she's not Arbor Fair
uh a villain ID or what vilified yeah
vilify she's a billionaire using a bully
uh
Pulpit to punch down at a violently
marginalized group
um then we got a two dollar Super Chat
from Artemis we need to imply to UB uh
ubt Universal basic income we need a two
dollar trip from 108 Dragon uh the pony
Master doesn't approve King's message
okay so everything after that we got
we're good
um yeah my fault for that you know what
it is I did copy paste all of those but
what I try to do is delete the the the
ones that are at the top and just leave
the ones the most recent ones and I
might have accidentally just deleted
everything and as far as you know the
the jk just look if if you fill oh wait
don't buy your game there's no way
around that like if if you truly feel
that way and there's a lot of people
that truly feel that way don't buy that
game but you cannot come at people for
not jumping on that either they they
want to play the game you know I I do
stand by there's a lot of people at that
studio that have nothing to do with her
statements that potentially going out
there and not buying that game off of
those statements can lead to another
massive lab because the game didn't do
it's like I said it's it's a Beyond gray
area thing it's a hard situation that
conversations have to be happening yeah
for sure
we have uh dicado put the crust into
chat for ducato welcome to Lord bronze
thank you so much
no doubt no doubt I think we're done no
doubt let's get up out of here Lord
addict where can I find people find you
what you got going on sir
you can find me on Twitter at Lord P you
can find me on my YouTube channel at
YouTube channel at gaming I got a couple
unique videos coming out one I've been
working on for three weeks and I I'm
about to have it done
um I'm I'm sure there's some people in
the community that's not going to
appreciate this video but oh I'm gonna
do it why I do everything uh watch if
you don't like just don't watch it so it
is what it is uh you can find me on r r
with the Lord the king you know this
week we're talking about uh King's
Adventures to attack on Titan have you
watched any more of that yet yes mind
your business okay so we won't be
talking about that
I don't want to promote something if you
haven't had time to watch it well that's
the same way that you said you don't
want them to go over there
oh my God can we not back at it baby I'm
sorry I didn't want a bunch of Gamers
that have no they don't care about that
field
watching it they're gonna look at it not
click it it's gonna hurt us so if I
don't if you don't want that content
it's okay you don't have to go I want
you over there I want to infect you
yeah
I gotta watch uh the the the great movie
I think that's what you said so you know
there's no Grinch movie It's called
violent night stop playing oh wow that's
not the Grinch movie you know there's a
grinch horror movie that came out
horrible
so definitely uh tune into that you know
I'll put it in the chat again if you
guys like entertainment TV movie uh
definitely go uh sub to this channel I
think you guys will enjoy it uh you know
we we have some stuff coming out man you
know me and Saul we're gonna work on
some stuff uh here momentarily hopefully
we'll get back at that Thursday the next
couple weeks to couple months of you
know we we will be going to packs here
soon and I think March isn't it March is
packs uh you know I appreciate all of uh
the super chats all the buy and all that
goes into uh back right straight back
into the company you guys showed up
pretty heavy today uh you know that that
bar went up like eight nine percent man
I appreciate everyone for coming through
supporting you know we're gonna give you
some uh some crazy content and hopefully
we'll get we'll get to uh some
announcements here soon no doubt Lord
solve we're gonna find people find what
you got going on Sir
downloading a whole bunch of games and
not playing them
[Laughter]
yeah man but uh shout out to Ty for
coming on man you know uh again there's
nothing like having someone come on
that's passionate about something and
speak about it intelligently and we
could bring a little bit of a different
flavor to it around I love that I love
that I can guarantee you what we just
done a lot of places aren't going to be
able to do that of course
no aggressive it was just grown men
having serious conversations about stuff
really into disagree respectfully but
I'm also getting additional context
shout out to Hogue what is it reasonable
Minds can't differ it's absolute dog man
he's doing some blessings like he's
doing better man salute the Hulk on that
rehab much love brother I'm pulling for
you I will reach out again just to check
on you and the wife it's a little it's
always it's good to see them active a
little bit I see him starting yeah yeah
I'm like
I was really worried that you know there
might be some long-term damage because
uh you know some really bad things can
happen from out the stroke but after I
saw that too and I was like man hoax
still but yeah thumbs worked so yeah
no doubt Lloyd King we're gonna find
people find you what you got going on
sir
well
the Gunnies is out here
they sound like an award show the
Gunnies you can catch me dipping past
the Gunnies because they on a snitch Mo
Christ
find me on Twitter kick David OTW where
I'm defending the realm against the
Gunnies they out here actively snitching
I don't understand for the life of me
when we come from a whole culture of
stop snitching not snitching this dude
is out here he said I'm not a part of
that life I don't identify with you and
I'm telling on that guy so again
catch me Tuesdays at 5 p.m with my man
attic wears a gunny free zone we just
talk about movies and entertainment uh
The Last of Us the next episode we'll be
talking about that I'll be talking about
frailty the movie and Attica be talking
about violent night Santa Claus gets
busy oh it's Santa Claus okay see these
people man I don't know what you got me
about the watch but it's dope as hell
um I'm watching some other stuff on
Netflix right now the second did you
watch the movie
huh did you watch the movie I told you
to watch by the way Realty yes mind your
business
it's all in my section
did you finish Baki I noticed we fell
off of bakis mind your business thank
you
and with that I rest my dude I forgot
actually I didn't do the poll oh wait
the additional positive response reviews
regarding high five Rush how do you want
Xbox to continue momentum in 2023 the
choices are eight more Stout launches
and surprises at events continue to
generate hype and wonder B commit to
their release date promises and hit them
consistently with their first party
releases see commit to Quality for their
games regardless of delays
I don't care I need my Starfield or else
those are the choices this is where it's
going down Rock the vote sorry gonna put
it up late I forgot about it we go check
that out and uh yeah it's me Laura
Coggin on Twitter um go check us out
again salute to everybody that pulled up
and allow us to have that difficult
conversation you know what I'm saying no
a lot of people don't do that for coming
through giving us some nuancy solve so
to everybody with the passion or the
panel so with everybody yo let people
enjoy games y'all for real like let
people live let them enjoy what they
want to enjoy I'm playing games
mind your business mind your business
that's what I get I'm probably gonna cry
myself to sleep because the names look
like they finish and Purdy is hurt and
they got some backups
he was popping bottles
Anything could happen like we were three
quarterbacks now we've lost the salute
about boys if they go down they went
down swinging and they didn't try to
give you some knowledge you try to tell
you slow down slow down
I got you in first road
gave me home all right let me get about
it anyway
bring it in
foreign
[Music]
thank you